Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 85. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen illustren Ausgabe von dem Bunte Bilder Podcast, wo man so Dinge erfährt über das Leben und das Universum und den ganzen Rest. Und heute ist wieder mal so ein Tag, wo das Thema etwas weiter greift als so das übliche und naheliegende elektronische und digitale, was uns ja sonst immer so weit bewegt. Und das Thema soll sein, Fliegen. Fliegen im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen. Und da zu jedem guten Thema auch ein Experte am Start gehört, habe ich auch wieder einen dabei. Das zweite Mal bei Chaosradio Express. Ich begrüße Björn Rupp, hallo.
Gut, dass wir keinen Video-Postkast haben, sonst würde ich das rot anlaufen.
Na, wieso? Du bist doch ein Experte.
Ja, wenn du das sagst.
Ja, also wenn du bist hier, also bist du ein Experte. Das ist die normative Kraft des Faktischen. Genau die. Na, wir haben ja auch schon mal ein Podcast gemacht zusammen, nämlich den Nummer 37, Chaosradio Express 37. Da spielt ja das Fliegen auch schon eine Rolle. Allerdings nur so ein bisschen am Rande. Da ging es um das Luftsicherheitsgesetz, was damals noch in Planung, das war, vielleicht kannst du noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, das ist schon so lange her.
Ja, es war leider nicht in Planung, sondern schon in voller Kraft. Und wir hatten uns ja damals über diese Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung unterhalten, die also Teil dieses handwerklich erlesenen Gesetzes ist. Und ja, also einige Teile dieses Gesetzes sind ja jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit höchstrichterlich verfassungswidrig und damit auch von der Bevölkerung entsorgt. Dieser Paragraph 7, wo es um die Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung geht, ist leider noch nicht so weit. Das heißt, da ist noch eine Verfassung beschwerdeanhängig. Aber wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass gut Ding Weile haben muss, besteht durchaus eine realistische Chance, dass das auch vor oder später gekippt wird, wie so manches, was in letzter Zeit wirklicherweise wissen schon. Und insofern besteht berechtigt, wir hoffen, dass das auch noch mal gekippt wird und eigentlich nach höchstrichterlichen Überprüfung nicht standhält. Also da gab es jetzt in letzter Zeit auch wieder so ein paar herrliche Anekdötchen, wo dann Leute, die irgendwie wegen 36 Euro irgendwo im Zahlungsverzug standen, dann direkt einen Post bekamen von der Luftfahrtbehörde, wo es dann hieß. Da seid ihr aber bestimmt nicht mehr zuverlässig so ungefähr. Also solche Schoten, das ist alles reichhaltiges Material, um diesen Paragrafen zu geben. Und dann ist das Thema hoffentlich irgendwann dann auch mal erledigt.
Und wann soll das? Gibt es da schon eine Datum, eine Aussicht?
Nein, leider nicht. Bis dahin müssen wir damit noch leben.
Aber das liegt schon beim Verfassungsgericht, plus Sie haben noch nicht gesagt, wann Sie darüber entscheiden wollen.
Die Beschwerde ist anhängig, aber frag mich jetzt nicht, wie der Juristische genauer läuft.
Okay, wir wollen jetzt auch das Luftsicherheitsgesetz nicht so sehr vertiefen, denn das haben wir ja schon gemacht. Chaosradio Express 37. Wen das interessiert, kann sich das mal anhören. Sehr kurzweilige 45-Minuten-Sendung. Aber genau in dieser Sendung bin ich so ein bisschen auf den Gedanken gekommen, dass man vielleicht das, was da noch so ein bisschen das Nebenwerk war, mal ein wenig neu aufgreift, nämlich das Thema Fliegen als solches. Das ist ja auch wieder so ein Thema, wie so manche bis viele, man weiß, dass es das gibt. Ja, man weiß, es gibt Leute, die sitzen in Flugzeugen und fliegen durch die Gegend, aber man hat eigentlich keinen richtig Kontakt oder Plan davon, weil das ja For the Chosen Ones ist oder wer auch immer. Ab und zu entdeckt man mal so in seinem Nachbarschaftskreis, unter seinem Freundeskreis mal jemanden, der hat einen Flugschein, und dann denkt man sich so, oh, ah, hm, wirklich und so. Und es ist ja interessant, als hätte er ihm gerade irgendwie erzählt, als hätte er irgendwie ein Auto mit drei Rädern oder sonst irgendwie Urlaub im Irak machen und so. Das ist schon so ein bisschen komisch. Genau. Und ich wollte jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen schwatzen über das Fliegen als solches, also was eigentlich alles so dazugehört und vor allem, und wir hatten ja auch schon kurz darüber gesprochen, ich habe ja auch schon mal über Hubschrauber gesprochen, dann muss ich natürlich auch als erstes mal fragen, was ist denn eigentlich ein Flugzeug? Also was macht ein Gerät beliebiger Art dazu, dass man es Flugzeug nennt?
Naja, also man könnte sich natürlich einfach mal das Wort genauer anschauen im Deutschen, also Flug und Zeug. Also in erster Linie ist es mal ein Zeug, was dann offensichtlich fliegen kann.
Was ist denn bitte ein Zeug? Ja, was ist denn das für ein Zeug?
Was das Flugzeug jetzt von einem Vogel unterscheidet, ist halt, dass es vom Menschen gemacht ist. Und ja, jetzt könnte man die Genealogie des Flugzeugs mal sehr detailliert beginnen zu durchleuchten. Ich will mir das mal sparen, man könnte jetzt bei ganz, ganz, ganz weit in der Vergangenheit anfangen, wo das halt hauptsächlich Träume waren.
Das ist ja noch nicht so lange her, dass das Träume waren.
Oh, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Wir nennen ja mal die Leonardo da Vinci.
Ach so, die Träume sind ja lange her, aber wo es sozusagen noch Träume waren, war es ja nicht so lange her. Also noch vor, was weiß ich, wann ist jetzt das erste Flugzeug? Also was ist denn das erste anerkannte, wirkliche Flugzeug? War das das, was die Brüder Wright gebaut haben oder waren die auch nicht die ersten?
Na, wie bei allem, was wirklich ein anerkanter Meilenstein in der Technikgeschichte ist, gibt es natürlich erbitterte nationale Streitigkeiten darüber, wer denn jetzt das erste Flugzeug und so weiter und so fort. Wie beim Telefon. Und wie bei allem, was wirklich komplexe Geschichte ist, die also aus allerlei Erkenntnissen profitiert, gibt es, denke ich, auch nicht nur einen einzigen Erfinder. Man könnte jetzt sagen, also ganz wesentlich aerodynamische Erkenntnisse kommen auf jeden Fall von Otto Lilienthal. Darauf kann man es, denke ich, speziell was Flügelprofile und ähnliches angeht. Da kann man sich nicht sagen, der hat ganz wesentliche Basisarbeit geleistet. Aber der erste Motorflug, und da wird es ja heute hauptsächlich darum gehen, um Motorfliegerei, der jetzt nicht nur ein Hüpfer war, sondern wirklich ein Flug mit einem definierten Beginn und Ende, wo sich das Flugzeug aus eigener Kraft eine Weile in der Luft hat halten können und nicht direkt danach wieder zum Boden geplumpst ist. Da ist schon ein Konsens da, dass das wirklich die Gebrüder Wright waren Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts. Und ja, das ist eigentlich... Das ist schon der Meilenstein in sich in Sachen.
Aber Otto Linienthal, okay, das ist dann sozusagen dann wieder mal... Am Ende haben es dann doch immer die Deutschen erfunden. Ich weiß, die Schweizer würden jetzt widersprechen. Aber es ist ja schon eine Nation, die bei technologischen Errungenschaften durchaus in der Geschichte verankert ist. Aber was hat er denn eigentlich rausgefunden? Also hat er jetzt wirklich schon so dieses heutzutage verwendete Flügelprofil erdacht oder war das eher Zufall?
Also Zufall war es ganz bestimmt nicht. Der ist sehr methodisch vorgegangen. Das heutzutage verwendete Flügelprofil ist aber wieder ein Thema. Da könnte man wieder eine halbe Stunde drüber sprechen. Ich glaube, wir haben ja noch einen. Also Flügelprofile sind ein komplexes Thema. Es gibt da ständig Neuentwicklungen, Laminaren, Fluss und so weiter. Aber der wesentliche Punkt, man kommt ja als Mensch relativ schnell, auch als Erddateiler, auf den Gedanken, so ein Vogel da oben, tolle Sache, hat zwei Flügel. Das muss doch eigentlich so gehen, wenn ich mir auch zwei Flügel an die Arme schnalle. Das muss doch auch auf mich funktionieren. Die Idee ist ja grundsätzlich nicht so ganz falsch, abgesehen davon, dass es mit den Armen, mit dem Muskelaufbau da ein bisschen knapp wird. Aber das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass es halt nicht reicht, nur zwei plane Bretter da dran zu hängen, sondern da muss halt ein Flügelprofil dran. Das heißt, wir wollen einen Auftrieb haben. Und das ist eigentlich auch was ganz Wesentliches, was wir beim Flugzeug, um da mal wieder auf zurückzukommen, auf jeden Fall brauchen, nämlich Auftrieb.
War denn Luft zu dem Zeitpunkt schon ein ausreichend verstandenes Phänomen? Also war man sich sozusagen über die Beschaffenheit mit Auftrieben und Abtrieben, ich meine, war das das, was er erst mal erfinden musste oder erkennen musste?
Na ja, Luft als solche. Es gibt bestimmt Leute, die auch heute sagen würden, das ist immer noch nicht richtig verstanden. Das ist eigentlich nur eine Frage, auf welches Granularitätsniveau wir da runtergehen wollen.
Ja, ich meine jetzt etwas wie der Begriff Aerodynamik.
Ja, das ist der entscheidende Punkt und ich denke gerade das Thema Auftrieb, also dass die Luft auf der Oberseite des Flügels schneller oder langsamer strömt, als auf der anderen Seite des Flügels. Naja, du willst ja, also Auftrieb ist eigentlich nicht, wie man häufig denkt, die Kraft, die sozusagen von unten den Flügel nach oben dreht, drückt, sondern eigentlich wird der Flügel nach oben gesaugt.
Oder gesogen.
Das ist ganz wesentlich dadurch halt bedingt, dass halt die Luft auf den beiden Seiten des Flügels unterschiedlich schnell strömt. Dadurch wird das dann nach oben gesaugt. Das ist jetzt eine sehr plastische Darstellung. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich das jetzt in diesem Rahmen bis ins letzte Detail erläutern kann, ohne eine Zeichnungshilfe zu nehmen.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht die Geschichte der aerodynamischen, aber das Grundprinzip sollte klar sein. Was strömt das jetzt schneller oder langsamer?
Wir brauchen den Auftrieb. Das ist der erste. Wenn ich da mal noch kurz zurück rudern darf. Um den Auftrieb zu bekommen, muss die Luft erst mal an dem Flügel anliegen. Das ist eigentlich wie beim Segeln. Das kann man sich auch ganz gut vorstellen. So ein Segel ist ja total prima. Aber wenn es keinen Wind gibt, hilft einem das tollste Segel auch nicht. Dann kommt das Segelboot nämlich nicht vorwärts. Genauso beim Flugzeug. Irgendwo muss die Luft ja möglichst von vorne anströmen, damit es auch das ganze gute Stück abhebt. Das heißt, wir brauchen dann auch eine Quelle an Energie, die das Flugzeug vorwärts bewegt. Jetzt können wir natürlich unser Segelflugzeug nehmen, das wir dann mit einer Winde oder mit einem Selbststarthilfe, also einem kleinen Motor, erst mal auf Höhe bringen. Und dann haben wir genug Energie, also Höhenenergie, in dem wir einfach Lageenergie nehmen, die wir dann umwandeln können in Vorwärtsbewegung. Oder wir nehmen halt einen Motor. Und das war das Entscheidende bei den Brüder Freit. Die haben es geschafft, einen Motor zu bauen, der leistungsfähig und leicht war. Und an dem Motor war dann damals und ist bis heute in vielen Fällen eine Luftschraube dran. Und da können wir wieder parallel zum Hubschrauberbeitrag bringen, vor einigen Sendungen. Im Prinzip ist ja die Luftschraube, die da vorne dran hängt, auch nur, klar, das ist natürlich alles eine ganz andere Steigung und so weiter und so fort. Aber im Prinzip ist das ja von der Sichtweite das Gleiche. Die Luftschraube erzeugt dann den Vortrieb. Das heißt, der Flügel wird angeströmt, das Flügelprofil wird angeströmt und aufwärts geht's. Dafür brauche ich natürlich genug Leistung und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt dann ein gewisses Profil, das heißt, die brauchen eine Mindestgeschwindigkeit, das kippe ich runter, das ist die sogenannte Abrissgeschwindigkeit. Dann habe ich auch irgendwelche Höchstgeschwindigkeiten, weil sonst meistens die Struktur des Flugzeugs überlastet wird und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt gibt es natürlich Triebwerke, könnte man auch wieder, kommen wir wahrscheinlich noch weiter zu, weiter differenzieren. Selbstverständlich sind wir nicht bei den guten alten Propeller-Triebwerken stehen geblieben.
Bevor wir vielleicht zu den Triebwerken kommen, finde ich auch interessant, aber wollte ich noch mal kurz zurück zu Otto Lilienthal, was jetzt sozusagen seine eigentliche Kernerkennnis war. Also er hat die Sache mit dem Auftrieb verstanden?
Ja, also wie gesagt verstanden, also er hat auf jeden Fall die, würde ich jetzt aus meiner Sicht sagen, die wichtigsten, grundlegenden ersten Einsichten daran gewonnen. Die also ganz fundamental und das ist jetzt, ich will das jetzt auch in keinster Weise schneller, aber man muss einfach sich auch überlegen, dass das Verständnis dieses Phänomens über 100 Jahre, die wir jetzt mittlerweile da haben, natürlich immer noch weiter ging. Also er hat, denke ich, ganz entscheidende grundlegende Arbeit in dem Bereich geleistet, die also überhaupt erst alles andere möglich gemacht hat. Also auch die Brüder of Rights haben ja auf dessen Erkenntnis durchaus auch zurückhalten dürfen. Und das in einer sehr systematischen Form. Also er hat ja unendlich viele Flüge von diesem kleinen Hügel gemacht mit seinen kleinen Gleitern. Er hat das systematisch aufgezeichnet, erfasst. Also das hatte eine ganz eigene Qualität. Das vorausgeschickt ist natürlich klar, dass über die Zeit, auch mit modernen, nicht zuletzt auch Computern, natürlich noch ein viel detaillierteres Verständnis von Strömungen an Flügeln, überhaupt von Wind umflossenen Objekten über die Zeit aufgebaut wurde. Und heute hast du Flügelprofile, die wären vor wenigen Jahren eigentlich noch gar nicht denkbar gewesen, weil du auch total glatte Oberflächen brauchst. Und da kommen wir wieder in das Thema Werkstoffe rein und so weiter und so fort.
Wie zum Beispiel dieses komische Stealth-Flugzeug der Amerikaner, dieses schwarze Teil.
Ja, das ist wieder ein anderes Thema. Da geht es ja in erster Linie darum, die Radareflexion abzuwenden.
Das hat ja so eine vollkommen absurde, gerade Kanten und so weiter.
Wie meinst du, das ist der F-117?
Ich höre mir jetzt gerade nicht sehen, was ich meine. Ich habe so ein Bild im Kopf von so einem relativ eckigen Teil.
Ja, du meinst da nicht den B-2-Bomber, der also so eine große Flunder ist, wie so eine Scholle, in der Mitte noch das Cockpixel, das leichte Bubble.
Das fällt mir jetzt auch ein, wo du gerade sagst, erzähl einfach mal was.
Du meinst F-117.
Aber das sind Beispiele für solche besonderen Formen, oder? Die jetzt am Anfang nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich gewesen wären, wenn man das nicht besser verstanden hätte.
Ist korrekt. Also gerade auch B-2 ist ja, da kann man, den könnte man in die Tradition der Nurflügler stellen. Kommt, glaube ich, auch nicht ganz hin, aber zumindest kann man ihn in diese Tradition stellen. Aber an so spektakulären Entwürfen will ich es jetzt gar nicht mehr festmachen. Selbst wenn du dir ein Segelflugzeug heute anguckst, was da an Technologien in den Flügeln drin steckt, ist einfach Wahnsinn. Und wie perfekt die verarbeitet sind durch neue Verbundwerkstoffe, das ist einfach unglaublich. Und da kann man halt auch als Universität schon sehr viel Forschung betreiben, zum Beispiel, ohne dass man jetzt gleich da ein Multimilliarden-Biget im Auftrag irgendeines Rüstungsabnehmers verbraten muss. Das ist hochinteressant.
Woraus ist denn so ein Flugzeug heute gebaut? Also wenn man jetzt so, angenommen, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Geld und ich habe irgendwie einen Chauffeur, da kann mir das Gerät auch jederzeit fliegen, wenn ich es jetzt selber nicht kann. Und jetzt kaufe ich mir mal ein Flugzeug. Also was kauft man sich denn so?
Ja, was kauft man sich denn so? Also wie bei allem.
Ja, ja, eine Frage des Preises. Aber wo fängt es denn eigentlich an? Was ist denn so der Golf?
Na, der Golf, also was ich ja immer sage, der VW Käfer, der Lüfte, ist eigentlich so die Chessner 152 bis 172. Also 172 ist dann der Viersitzer. Das ist so der Käfer der Lüfte. Ja, läuft und läuft und läuft und läuft. Ist aus den 70ern. Funktioniert immer noch, ist unkaputtbar. Kann eigentlich nicht so richtig toll, aber in der Summe halt doch eine ganze Menge echt gut. Also es ist weder das schnellste Flugzeug, noch das mit der größten Zuladung, noch mit dem tollsten Motor oder sonst was der tollsten Technik. Aber in der Summe seiner Eigenschaften einfach ein sehr brauchbares Flugzeug, was dann doch eine ganze Menge kann. Das ist so der...
Das ist schon richtig alt, ne?
Das ist vom Design her, wie sehr viele Flugzeuge, gerade die kleineren, alt. Also die 70er Jahre waren ja so die Hochzeit der Privatfliegerei, wo unglaubliche Innovationen speziell in US-Amerika passiert ist. Und da zählen viele heute noch von. Klar, mittlerweile sind wir wieder weiter. Aber ich springe nochmal zurück zu der ursprünglichen Frage, aus was ist denn so ein Flugzeug gebaut? Du könntest jetzt, wenn du Spaß dran hättest, könntest du noch so ein richtig krachsimples Flugzeug, das ist so ein Piper Cup zum Beispiel, Design aus den 40ern. Gibt es halt auch, ja es gibt auch Nachbaut, mittlerweile auch neu, aber im Prinzip ist das so ein 40er-Jahre-Flugzeug. Das macht einfach Spaß, muss man dazu sagen. Das ist so ein Gitterrohrrahmen, ganz früher waren die natürlich noch aus Holz, aber jetzt, wenn wir jetzt mal doch in die Jetztzeit, was heutzutage noch fliegt, reinschauen, haben wir so ein Gitterrohrrahmen und der ist tatsächlich mit Stoff bespannt. Also, sowohl Flügel als auch Zelle, das ist eigentlich ein festbespannter Stoff, der dann noch schön angemalt ist. Das ist natürlich sehr leicht, ein großer Vorteil und wenn man schön aufpasst, dass das darunter liegende Gitterrohrgerüst nicht rostet und obendrüber alles schön angestrichen ist und fest ist, ist das sogar ganz brauchbar. Irgendwann kam dann natürlich die Bewegung zum Ganzmetallflugzeug, das ist jetzt auch wieder eine Geschichte. Das Spiel namens Viyunkas hat eine große Rolle und heute sind mit stoffbespannte Flugzeuge nur noch in der sehr leichten Klasse zu finden. Also gibt es immer noch, also auch so eine Robin, die hat sogar noch Holz, die ist sogar noch aus Holz gebaut, sogar heute noch, da muss ich mich eben korrigieren, und ist dann mit stoffbespannt. Es gibt also heute noch zuverlässige Flugzeuge, aber die meisten sind da doch in Metall gebaut, ganz Metall. Und was jetzt die neuere Entwicklung ist, die mittlerweile auch schon nicht mehr so neu ist, also das war vor 20 Jahren noch total undenkbar, oder nicht undenkbar, sonst gedacht wurde es ja, aber vor 20 Jahren auch wirklich, also total brandneu und unglaublich. Das ist halt der Glasfaser, bzw. besser gesagt Verbundwerkstofftrennen, dass du also Flugzeuge nicht mehr mit so einer klassischen Chassis baust, die dann irgendwo zusammengenietet wirst, und du hast eigentlich Lappen, oder? Sozusagen, die kommen dann in den Ofen, werden fertig gebacken und dann werden noch zwei Hälften sozusagen miteinander verbunden. Und du hast eigentlich wirklich fertig gebackene Flugzeuge, sozusagen. Und das ist schon faszinierend, weil diese Verbundwerkstoffe noch mal eine ganze Ecke widerstandsfähiger sind als traditionelles Metall und auf ihre Weise auch einen Oberflächenfinish ermöglichen, was du mit Metall niemals hinkriegst. Also, da gibt es halt keine Nieten, kein Nichts.
Das ist so ein einziger Durchgehenderkörper.
Ja, und es ist halt wirklich, du kannst wunderbar, du kannst das nochmal polieren und schmirgeln, dann ist es wirklich, wirklich wunderbar glatt. Ja, das kriegst du also mit Metall, wo ja immer irgendwelche Nieten und Ösen und sonst was ist so nicht hin und ja, das ist schon eine faszinierende Entwicklung. Und da geht auch der Trend hin, da gab es ja auch viele Diskussionen jetzt, wenn man jetzt in die große Luft wieder zurückgeht, Stichwort Boeing 787 Dreamliner, aber auch noch ein Airbus-Modell, die eigentlich auch noch früher angefangen haben, da geht halt auch der Trend dazu, dass, obwohl die immer noch hauptsächlich aus Metall gebaut werden, das Aluminium, Luftfahrt-Aluminium, immer mehr Teile jetzt so langsam aus Verbundwerkstoffen da ihren Weg auch in die großen Flugzeuge finden.
Stimmt, jetzt wo du es erwähnst, ich wollte ja eigentlich sehr viel mehr über kleine, affordable Flugzeuge reden, aber jetzt wo du es gerade erwähnst, also das hatte ich jetzt auch erst kürzlich zur Kenntnis genommen, dass dieser Dreamliner, das ist dann sozusagen die erste Verkehrsmaschine, die was vollständig aus Glasfaser gemacht hat oder weitgehend.
Ich habe irgendwie eine Formulierung gefunden, von der ich nicht mehr genau weiß, wie sie war. Weder die ersten noch weitgehend, das kann man eigentlich nicht sagen, aber zumindest ist das ein Flugzeug, was auch den Trend dazu unterstreicht. Es werden halt immer mehr Bestandteile aus Verbundwerkstoffen gebaut, wo man vor Jahren noch gesagt hat, ne, das machen wir aber nicht, da bleiben wir beim Mutal.
So wie die Flügel oder was? Was ist denn beim A380, ist das komplett Metall?
Ich als erfahrener Luftfahrtingenieur, aus meiner Entwicklungsgeschichte beim A380. Also in den ersten Jahren muss ich sagen, nein, aber das ist auch ein Hybrid-Design. Also das ist immer noch hauptsächlich aus Metall, aber es gibt halt sehr viele Teile mittlerweile, die aus Verbundwerkstoff sind.
Und diese Chesna, diese 150er-Serie, die du schon angesprochen hast, wenn das jetzt so der Käfer ist, also das Ding hier irgendwie, Müller hat gesagt, 1959 ist das Ding schon entwickelt worden. Alter Falter, das Teil ist ja uralt, fast 50 Jahre. Ist das jetzt aus Metall noch oder wird das auch mittlerweile mit Verbund gemacht?
Nee, das ist immer ein ganz klassisches Design.
Okay, vielleicht können wir uns mal das Ding ja mal als Beispiel nehmen. Das ist auch die, mit der wir mal geflogen sind, oder?
Wir sind sowohl mit der kleinen 152er, als auch mit der großen Schwester in Anführungsstrichen, Viersetzer, 172er sind wir auch schon geflogen.
Aha, okay. Ja, das war ganz interessant. Aber was ich jetzt so einem bemerkenswert, also ich fand eine ganze Menge Sachen ziemlich bemerkenswert, als wir da mal geflogen sind. Nicht unbedingt jetzt in der Reihenfolge, wie ich sie wahrgenommen habe, aber was das Flugzeug betrifft, fand ich es einfach bemerkenswert, wie wenig da drin ist, also aus wie wenig ein Flugzeug eigentlich bestehen muss, um als solches dann auch zu funktionieren und auch fliegen zu dürfen. Man ist beim Auto mal heutzutage gewohnt, mein Gott, wenn das nicht ABS hat und irgendwie 30 Airbags, ja dann darf das nicht auf die Straße gestellt werden. Dann möchte man jetzt im Umkehrschluss denken, so, oh Gott, wenn es jetzt in die Lüfte geht und so, dann brauchen wir noch alle möglichen dreifache Raketensitze, Fallschirme. Und ja, also wenn man den gleichen Sicherheitswahn hat, dann natürlich ist jetzt die Zahl an Leuten, die auf der Straße verkehren, mit der Luftstraße so rechtlich zu vergleichen. Aber schon interessant zu sehen, in was für eine arkane Welt man auf einmal dort einsteigt, obwohl das ja immer so mit Hightech und Zukunft und, ja, ich denke nur Luftautos und so weiter assoziiert ist. Also was ist denn überhaupt drin in so einer Cessna?
Naja, zunächst mal kurz auf das Thema Autos und da ist alles so viel mit Airbag und Elektronik, ja. Man könnte es auch genau umdrehen und zu sagen, naja, in der Luft möchtest du dich umdrehen und zu sagen, wir sind ganz Elektronikprobleme, die müssen sich auch noch rumschlagen, ja. Also nach dem Motto, der Bordcomputer sagt, hm, da ist aber der Motor kaputt, stellen sie doch mal ab, ja. Blöde Sache eigentlich. Also es muss ja gar nicht immer diese Elektronik sein. Es gibt zwar natürlich auch gerade in den letzten Jahren irre viel Fortschritte, das Schiefwort da heißt Glas-Cockpits, wo du dann im Prinzip auch deinen fliegenden Computer vor dir hast, der das alles flugsimulatormäßig vor dir darstellt. Aber was du eigentlich brauchst, ist echt wenig. Zumal jetzt, um nochmal auf diese Piper Cup zurückzukommen, ja, bin ich auch schon geflogen, da gibt es überhaupt kein elektrisches System, kein Elektrik. Den Motor lässt du mit der Hand an.
Ach, das ist noch so wie damals, so mit rumpumpum.
Ja, genau. Da hältst du dich noch wirklich vor das Flugzeug, stellst bitte vorher sicher, dass der Flugzeug nicht wegrollt, wenn der Motor dann an ist, dann reißt du am Propeller.
Wie schenkt man das sicher? Man muss dann so diese Keile unter die Räder machen oder was?
Dann reißt du am Propeller, strittst dann schnell zurück, weil dann der Propeller natürlich anfängt, sich zu drehen. Ja, und dann steigst du ein und fliegst los. Ja, das ist sehr unspursprünglich. Da gibt es dann auch keinen Funk, weil es gibt ja keine Elektrik.
Wenn die Klötze dann weg sind, wie hält man das Ding dann an?
Ja, du hast ja schon deine Bremsen dann auch innen drin.
Okay, es gibt schon Bremsen und dann macht man den Motor irgendwann aus.
Ja, wenn du wieder gelandet bist, kannst du auch nicht wieder ausbremsen. Das ist halt wirklich simpel. Da gibt es auch nicht viel an Avionik drin. Da gibt es sehr wenige Instrumente. Du weißt also, wie hoch du fliegst und die essentiellen Informationen. Aber sonst ist da einfach nichts drin. Und das funktioniert ganz hervorragend. Also da gibt es hier ja Exemplare. Die fliegen jetzt, wie gesagt, schon seit der Mitte der 40er und fliegen immer noch. Heutzutage hast du natürlich auch in so einem, um jetzt mal auf den Käfer der Lüfte nochmal zurückzukommen, da gibt es natürlich schon Elektrik. Funken ist ja schon eine praktische Sache. Das will man eigentlich schon haben. Denn man möchte ja schon mal mit den Leuten in den anderen Flugzeugen und vor allem mit denen am Boden mal sprechen können. Erleichtert die Dinge ungemein. Dann willst du schon grundlegende Fluglageinstrumente, möchtest du auf jeden Fall auch haben. Das heißt, du hättest gerne den besagten Höhenmesser. Dann so ein künstlicher Horizont ist auch total praktisch.
Damit du mal weißt, ob das... Also, was für Instrumente sind denn in diesem Teil? Gibt es da überhaupt welche?
Also, da gibt es unterschiedliche Modellvarianten bis zur Super Cup und so weiter.
Aber was könnte man alles weglassen? Also, was ist sozusagen das Minimum, was man braucht, um ein Flugzeug nicht nur betreiben zu können, sondern auch betreiben zu dürfen? Also, was muss da drin sein?
Also, was man auf jeden Fall, ohne dass ich jetzt die Zulassungsvorschriften aus dem Kopf zitieren möchte oder könnte, was auf jeden Fall mal total praktisch ist, ist eine Fahrtmesseanzeige. Du möchtest ja wissen, wie schnell du bist, denn du möchtest nicht unter eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit fallen, wie ich am Anfang schon sagte. Irgendwann fällst du dann runter, beziehungsweise der Luftstrom liegt halt nicht mehr an. Das heißt, du hast den sogenannten Stall, also Abriss der Strömung am Flügel. Und dann hast du deinen Auftrieb nicht mehr und dann geht's halt abwärts.
Okay. Welche Geschwindigkeit brauchen wir so zum Abheben?
Das ist halt je nach Flugzeugtyp total unterschiedlich. Da geht's dann auch wirklich ans Eingemachte des Flugzeugdesigns. Das ist halt total faszinierend. Es gibt, also typischerweise ist halt so, dass Flugzeuge, die Profile und einen Design haben, was mit einer sehr geringen Mindestgeschwindigkeit schon das Abheben ermöglicht. Dann dafür aber auch am oberen Ende des Envelopes, also des Rahmens.
Der Preiskaler.
Nee, nicht der Preiskaler, sondern der Leistungskaler. Wenn du halt natürlich relativ schnell in der Luft bist, mit sehr geringer Geschwindigkeit, heißt das normalerweise auch, naja, dann kannst du aber nicht irre schnell werden. Weil es gibt da irgendwo Design-Trait-offs. Es gibt jetzt einige Flugzeuge, einige wenige. Das ist dann wirklich die hohe Kunst des Engineering, die in Ingenieurskunst, die sehr schnell sind, also wirklich richtig flott Tempo machen können und trotzdem recht langsam fliegen können. Das wird dann meistens dadurch realisiert, dass dann da Riesenklappen ausgefahren werden.
Was meinen Sie, wenn sie schnell sind, aber können langsam fliegen? Also sie haben eine hohe Höchstgeschwindigkeit.
Sie haben eine hohe Höchstgeschwindigkeit.
Was ist schnell? Also was bezeichnest du jetzt als schnell?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch relativ, aber wenn ich jetzt mal ein Beispiel nehme, nehme ich mal so eine richtig schnelle Sokarta TBM 850. Das ist eine einmotorige Turboprop, fliegt über 300 Knoten Reisegeschwindigkeit. Also das ist schnell und kann aber trotzdem, ich glaube, die hat eine Anfluggeschwindigkeit, also Approach vor der Landung, ohne dass ich jetzt genau wüsste, aber das liegt auch so im Bereich irgendwo um 80 Knoten herum. Plus, Minus, 20, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, aber jedenfalls für so ein High-Performance-Flugzeug ausgesprochen zahm.
300 Knoten sind 555,6 Stundenkilometer. Hab ich gerade ausgerechnet. Im Kopf natürlich.
Bin total beeindruckt.
Also in meinem elektronischen Kopf.
Ja und dieses Flugzeug ist zum Beispiel so ein Flugzeug, was insofern einen sehr großen Performance-Envelope, einen sehr großen Leistungsspektrum abdeckt von der Geschwindigkeit. Und das realisieren die unter anderem dadurch, dass wenn das Flugzeug langsam wird, man da riesige Klappen ausfahren kann. Dadurch wird die Flügelfläche vergrößert. Dadurch wird der Antrieb größer.
Die schieben sich dann so hinten so raus. Genau. Das ist auch so bei Verkehrsmaschinen.
Ja, also Klappen hast du ja heutzutage eigentlich bei jedem modernen Flugzeug. Nur, wie die dann genau gebaut sind und wie groß die sind und wie die ausfahren, das ist wieder ein Thema für sich. Und da fangen dann die vielen kleinen Tricks an, wo du wirklich sagen kannst, toll ist diese eine.
Okay, jetzt waren wir ja sozusagen erstmal bei der Mindestausstattung eines Flugzeugs. Du hast gesagt, Fahrtenmesser ist klar, weil wir müssen irgendwie wissen, wie schnell wir sind. So, wie der misst dann sozusagen den Luftdruck, der von vorne kommt, oder wie, oder was, so ein Röhrchen. Sind das diese Röhrchen da vorne? Genau. Das heißt, da ist so ein Rohr nach vorne, da wird die Luft reingedrückt und da nimmt er dann sozusagen an, wie schnell er ist. Weil sonst gibt es ja in dem Sinne keinen, man könnte ja auch die Sterne anpeilen, aber ich glaube, das wäre nicht besonders erfolgreich, oder?
Das wäre nicht besonders folglich. Das Interessante ist jetzt natürlich, was du ja bei dem Fahrtenmesser dann hast, ist erstmal die Indicated Airspeed, also die Geschwindigkeit gegenüber der umgebenden Luft. Das ist ja nicht identisch mit der Geschwindigkeit über Grund. Das sind also auch die feinen Details, die man dann relativ schnell unterscheiden muss. Aber das ist schon mal ganz entscheidend, um überhaupt ein Gefühl dafür zu haben, bei welcher Geschwindigkeit kann ich denn in der Luft bleiben? Und wie schnell bin ich denn denn? Wenn du langsam über Grund bist, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass du auch langsam gegenüber der umgebenden Luft bist.
Kann sein, dass dir der Sturm einfach direkt ins Gesicht bläst.
Zum Beispiel. Du kannst ja auch mit dem Flugzeug unter Umständen in der Luft stehen, wenn du einen richtig starken Gegenwind hast. Nicht schlecht.
Wozu dann noch Hubschrauber? Okay, aber was außer dem Fahrtenmesser?
Höhe möchte man auch ganz gerne wissen, wie hoch man denn eigentlich ist.
Auch das ist wieder Luftdruck?
Das geht normalerweise barometrisch. Also das heißt, ich stelle unten am Boden ein, dann weiß ich ja, wie hoch ich bin.
Und man muss jedes Mal nullen, wenn man steht.
Man sollte eigentlich am besten das nicht nur dann machen, wenn man am Boden ist, sondern auch in regelmäßigen Abständen, wenn man jetzt über größere Stecken fliegt. Ändert sich ja das Wetter und der lokale Luftdruck. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt angenommen, ich würde jetzt hier von Berlin in die Schweiz fliegen und würde immer mit dem gleichen Luftdruck fliegen, den ich eingestellt habe, habe ich wahrscheinlich früher oder später, wenn die Wetterlagen vor Ort unterschiedlich sind, wo er von auszugehen ist, habe ich zum Schluss eine falsche Anzeige, weil ja der Luftdruck in der Gegenkartonne. Und genau, da bin ich ja sozusagen falsch geeicht.
Wie gleich sind das Messen? Ich kann auch nicht irgendwie nullen, wenn ich in der Luft bin.
Deswegen habe ich ja wieder das Tolle-Funkgerät am Boden. Da frage ich unten mal nach. Geben Sie doch mal Ihren Luftdruck. Das nennt sich dann QNH. Dann stelle ich das wieder ein auf dieser kleinen Skala, die ich da im Höhenmesser habe. Und dann auf wunderbare Weise ändert sich meine Höhe, zumindest die angezeigte natürlich.
Okay, verstehe. Und was muss da noch für ein Instrument drin sein?
Das ist so ein nützliches Instrument. Dann so ein Wendezeiger hätte man auch ganz gerne. Der hilft einem Standardkurven zu fliegen. Da ist eine kleine Kugel auch unten, die dann immer in der Mitte bleiben muss. Dann fliegt man eine saubere koordinierte Kurve. Dann der Künstliche Horizont, den hatte ich schon erwähnt. Da sieht man, ob die Nase nach unten oder nach oben geht. Welche Schräglage ich habe, kann man auch sehen, mit wie viel Grad Querlage ich fliege. Die Motorüberwachung ist auch praktisch. Es ist immer gut zu wissen, ob er noch läuft. Ob er noch läuft, wie schnell er denn läuft. Da kann man dann natürlich jetzt auch wieder beliebig expandieren, je nachdem, wie viel man darüber wissen möchte. Also im Minimum ist die Drehzahl sicherlich schon total hilfreich. Dann sind so Dinge wie Öltemperatur natürlich durchaus von Interesse. Man könnte sich jetzt auch noch über die Zylindertemperaturen unterhalten und so weiter und so weiter. Da kann man also dann wieder dann...
Da wird es aber schon ein bisschen nerdy.
Das wird schon ein bisschen nerdy.
Das brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Und was davon ist jetzt in der in dem Käfer, in der 150er Cessna drin? All das?
Das ist eigentlich alles drin.
Und das ist jetzt auch schon alles, was drin ist oder ist da noch was drin?
Ja, da gibt es natürlich jetzt noch allerlei andere Geräte, je nach Ausstattungsstand. Aber jetzt haben wir jetzt erstmals mal diese ganzen... Wir haben da einen Kreiselkompass. Das heißt, wir brauchen da schon mal einen Antrieb für das Gyroskop. Der funktioniert in diesen Flugzeugen über Unterdruck. Das heißt, ich habe da eine Vakuumpumpe. Und ich habe dann zumal auch noch ein weiteres klitzekleines Instrument, das mir anzeigt, ob auch die Vakuumpumpe genug Vakuum liefert. Nur so ein kleines Detail.
So zum Beispiel auch das Vakuum, damit der Kreisel sozusagen freikreiseln kann.
Kann man auch elektrisch machen, aber das wurde halt da immer so geregelt.
Kann man vielleicht auch noch benutzen, einen kleinen Tuschrank.
Dann fangen wir mit dem Thema Navigation an. Man kann natürlich immer runtergucken. Aha, hier ist ein Bauernhof. Das wird wohl hinter Tupfingen sein. Aber früher oder später regt sich dann doch der Wunsch, das doch etwas präziser und unabhängig von Bodenmerkmalen bestimmen zu können. Und dann fangen wir halt an mit Peilempfingern. Der einfachste ist der ADF, Automatic Direction Finder. Das ist ein klassisches Mittelwellenradio, was dir ungefähr sagt, da steht der Sender. Das hilft dir schon mal, aber noch toller sind natürlich die so genannten Bio-Rs, VHF, Omni-Directional Ranges, das heißt UKW-Drehfunkfeuer. Der sagt dir genau, du stehst von diesem Drehfunkfeuer jetzt genau so und so viel Grad davon entfernt.
Wie weiß er das? Also das Drehfunkfeuer heißt, das Ding dreht sich wie so ein Leuchtturm oder was?
Das ist die Idee, aber es dreht sich jetzt nicht wirklich, sondern du hast also in der Praxis hast du Antennen, die einmal drum rumgehen, also im Kreis, also wenn du so ein Bio-R auch mal siehst, entweder aus der Luft oder kannst du dir das vorstellen, das sind dann meistens so kreisförmige, also was heißt meistens, das sind kreisförmige Gebilde.
Wenn sie nicht kreisförmig sind, abdrehen, irgendwas ist nicht in Ordnung.
Stell dir so eine kleine Sonne vor mit ihren Sonnenstrahlen und diese Sonnenstrahlen sind die einzelnen Antennen, da läuft das Signal einmal rum und der Empfänger ist so schlau zu wissen, ok, jetzt kommt das Signal von da, das heißt, ich bin also so und so viel Grad von diesem Drehfunkfeuer entfernt.
Weil das Signal über jede Antenne ein bisschen anders ist oder was?
Und wenn ich jetzt zwei von diesen Drehfunkfeuern entweder hintereinander oder noch besser, dass er komfortabel ist, habe ich dann zwei von diesen Empfängern, das ist dann schon der erste Hauch des Luxus, also von einem sehr niedrigen Niveau ausgehend. Dann kann ich eine Kreuzpeilung machen, dann weiß ich ja auf der Karte, ok, ich habe hier das Drehfunkfeuer 1, das Drehfunkfeuer 2, das eine ist links von mir, das andere ist rechts von mir. Ich bin so und so viel Grad von dem einen, so und so viel Grad von dem anderen. Das heißt, ich kann da schöne Linien von jedem Drehfunkfeuer zeichnen und der Punkt, in dem wir die beiden Linien schneiden, das ist eine tolle Sache.
Das heißt, da sitzt man wirklich mit so einem Dinner-Null-Bogen und sowieso wieder Kapitän von dem großen Tisch und dann so, wir müssen mal unsere Route neu bestimmen.
So ungefähr. Das ist so ein ganz klassischer Navigationsboden.
Nur, dass so viel Platz ja nicht ist in diesen Dingern. Da ist ja schon alles sehr beengt.
Wir sprachen ja von VW Calfran. Wir können ja auch den Bus, könnten wir ja auch uns zulegen.
Was ist denn der VW-Bus?
Der VW-Bus wäre dann auch wieder von Cessna, um im Bild zu bleiben. Das wäre dann wahrscheinlich so die, ja, also mindestens die 206, also so ein Sechs-Sitzer oder ein Turbo-T210. Das wären dann schon so Flugzeuge, wo einfach unglaublich viel an Ladung reinpasst. Bisschen mehr Platz ist, die aber eigentlich immer noch so aussehen, auch eigentlich ungefähr so funktionieren, also auch immer noch so. Und das wären dann bei Cessna sind das traditionell immer Schulterdecker.
Also die Flügel oben über dem Cockpit.
Genau.
Was ja ganz schön ist, weil dann steigt man aus und wird nicht gleich nass, wenn es regnet.
Ja, du kannst halt schön runtergucken.
Man kann schon runtergucken? Ah ja, genau, stimmt. Das habe ich jetzt wieder nicht beleuchtet.
Und das ist natürlich vor allem den Vorteil, dass der Schwerpunkt halt unten ist und dadurch lässt sich das relativ einfach fliegen.
Jetzt sind wir ja schon so ein bisschen bei der Bedienung. Dann machen wir es doch mal vielleicht mal ganz praktisch. Ich habe gerade auf die Idee gekommen, ganz pfiffig. Wollen wir nicht mal losfliegen? Also jetzt mal so virtuell.
Ja, ich suche gerade hier nach dem... Ich habe hier das Audio.
Wo wollen wir denn mal hin? Ich spult vor mir. Nicht an den Knöpfen drehen. Ne, wir machen das einfach mal ganz virtuell. Wir sind ja schon mal geflogen und ich weiß, da waren jetzt so zahlreiche Maßnahmen. Die kriege ich jetzt auf gar keinen Fall wieder zusammen. Aber vielleicht können wir das ja einfach mal machen. So, ich meine, als Erstes braucht man ein Flugzeug. Wo kriege ich das her?
Naja, also wenn du nicht gerade eins gekauft hast, wie du ja gerade vorhattest, also ich unterstütze dich dabei, sag mir Bescheid. Kannst du mir dann auch mal ausleihen. Kannst es dir mieten, genau wie ein... Also entweder du kannst es im Verein machen, ja, also wie ein Segelflugverein oder ein anderen Verein, wo du als Mitglieds... Am Rahmen der Mitgliedschaft so ein Flugzeug dir leihen, bzw. mieten kannst. Oder du kannst ganz einfach mieten, wie bei einem Mietwagenverleih, ja.
Das ist in der Regel angedockt an einen Flugplatz.
Ja, das ist immer angedockt an einem bestimmten Flugplatz. So diese One-Way-Charter oder One-Way-Mieten, wie beim Autovermieten gibt es leider in dem Bereich nicht in dem Umfang.
Und es gibt auch in der Regel immer nur pro Flugplatz eine Vermieteinheit. Also es ist mehr oder weniger der Flugplatz der Vermieter? Oder gibt es wirklich Flugplätze, wo so mehrere Anbieter sind?
Das ist nicht gesagt. Also es gibt selbst an kleinen Plätzen durchaus auch mehr als einen Vercharterer, der dann die Maschinen verchartert.
Also das heißt, man ruft da irgendwie an und sagt, ich bräuchte jetzt mal ein Flugzeug.
Genau.
Hab da gerade eins da. Ja dann, ja Herr Rupp, wir haben irgendwie hier eine Cessna 152. Sie kennen das Modell sehr bewährt. Zwei Plätze reicht Ihnen ja wohl heute.
Und dann sagst du, irgendwie stellt es schon mal kalt, ich setze mich ins Auto und dann fährt man zum Flugplatz.
Ja, warmstehen ist eigentlich noch besser, weil dann das Öl ja im Motor, das wäre lieber warm als kalt.
Achso, ja, müssen die dann, also macht dann der Flugplatz schon irgendwas mit dem Ding oder steht es einfach so lange rum, muss man auf oder wird da tatsächlich irgendwas angeschlossen?
Das ist dann genau wie die Frage, ob du jetzt mit Autovermieter A oder B unterwegs bist. Also ob du es dann auch geputzt haben möchtest oder vollgetankt oder nicht. Also normalerweise kannst du das vorher sagen und dann wird das bei einem netten Verchargerer auch alles so vorher erledigt. Es gibt aber auch welche, da musst du halt das Flugzeug selber aus der Halle rausholen. Also so viel ist da aber auch eigentlich nicht vorher zu tun.
Okay, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal Bare Bones, Rentals und machen alles selber. Das heißt, wir fahren jetzt zum Flugplatz und kommen da an. Dann gibt es sicherlich die eine oder andere Formalier so. Und dann marschiert man irgendwie zur Halle, macht das Tor auf und holt sich das Teil raus.
Ja, und das Tolle ist natürlich, dass die Formalien ja innerhalb von, wir sehen, Sekunden- oder Minutenschnelle erledigt sind. Das ist halt wirklich das Schöne. Du kommst da halt an. Gerade an so einem kleinen Flugplatz, nehmen wir mal einen ganz einfachen Flugplatz, Bärbuns mit Graspiste. Du hast jetzt vom Auto bis zum Flugzeug, hast du vielleicht wenige Meter Fußweg. Ja, und du kannst eigentlich direkt einsteigen und nicht losfliegen, weil wir natürlich vorher noch den Vorflugcheck machen wollen. Also wir wollen erst mal schauen, wie es denn überhaupt aussieht mit dem Flugzeug, ja?
Das ist auch Pflicht?
Das ist Pflicht und ist auch extrem sinnvoll. Du willst ja vorher noch mal gucken, ob alles dran ist und alles so dran ist, wie es ist. Dann willst du gucken, ob genug Öl drin ist und ganz wichtig, ob natürlich genug Sprit drin ist. Du hast ja vorher ausgerechnet, wie lange wollen wir denn fliegen.
Das heißt, man muss erst mal rumrennen und die Anzahl Flügel zählen und so.
Und wie du dir schon denken kannst, so Anzahl Flügel zählen, das geht relativ fix. Und je simpler so ein Flugzeug, der zu schneller geht, auch diese Vorflugkontrolle.
Was muss man jetzt so checken?
Na, wir gehen jetzt mal bei der Cessna, hier ist mal um die Virtuele Cessna, die wir hier gerade, ich stelle es gerade, schreidimensional entfaltet haben. Ich stelle dir dieses Mischpult hier vor, wir laufen jetzt hier einmal darum. Und was überprüfen wir da? Zum einen mal, ob die Struktur denn, die Zelle so ist, wie sie sein sollte. Da gibt es keine dicken Dellen drin, da sind keine losen Schrauben. Die Klappen sind alle mit ihren Schrauben und den passenden Muttern vollständig vorhanden. Die Höhen- und Seitenruder werden korrekt angelängt. Die ganzen kleinen Rohre, von denen wir eben gesprochen haben, nämlich Pitot-Rohr-Statik.
Also man muss sie schon so reinsetzen und dann auch an den Hebeln ziehen, sozusagen.
Das kommt dann spät, wir laufen jetzt erstmal draußen drumrum.
Ach so, also Höhenruder, das heißt, man fasst da sozusagen an und klappt. Okay, wie viele Roder gibt es?
Na, es gibt einen Höhenruder, einen Seitenruder und einen Querruder.
So, und das Höhenruder ist welches? Das ist das an den großen Flügeln?
Ne, das Höhenruder ist das hinten am Heckleitwerk, was nach oben und unten sich dreht. Und damit geht es, wie man schon vermuten könnte, nach oben und unten.
An den kleinen Flügeln hinten, okay. Und dann gibt es das Seitenruder.
Das Seitenruder ist auch wieder, da bleiben wir wieder am Heckleitwerk, nur das geht jetzt halt vertikal. Und da geht es halt nach links und rechts. Und jetzt haben wir noch ganz toll die Querruder, die sind in den Flügeln drin. Und die brauchen wir, um eine koordinierte Flüge, koordinierte Kurve zu fliegen. Wenn wir das jetzt nur mit dem Seitenruder machen würden, würde das nämlich so schieben in der Kurve. Und eine koordinierte Kurve machen wir dann mit dem Seitenruder und den Querrudern gleichzeitig. Und dann legen wir uns wunderschön koordiniert in so eine schöne Kurve.
Aber sonst würde es übersteuern, wie man bei Autos sagt.
Ja, so könnte man das sagen.
Oder untersteuern, das kriegt man auch mal durch. Ich glaube, in dem Fall. Wenn es schiebt, ist es übersteuert.
Also wir gehen jetzt davon aus, die sind alle in Ordnung.
Aber es gibt diese drei Ruder, es ist ja auch schon mal interessant, noch mal festzuhalten, weil ich denke auch nicht jedem ist klar, wie so ein Flugzeug eigentlich funktioniert. Ich meine, man sitzt immer in diesen großen Verkehrsmaschinen. Da sind so riesige Monster-Düsen dran und dann machen die kurz und dann ist man irgendwie in der Luft. Und hier ist es halt irgendwie alles noch sehr einfach.
Ja, man kann sich das, also im Prinzip ist ja so ein großes Flugzeug auch von den Grundfunktionen auch nicht sehr viel anders als so ein kleines. Nur die Systeme dahinter werden halt immer komplexer, aber so, die haben auch drei Ruder, die haben auch Klappen. Also im Prinzip, das Prinzip bleibt schon immer das Gleiche. Nur die Komplexität der Systeme, dahinter wird halt immer größer.
So, jetzt haben wir die Ruder gecheckt.
Ja, wir haben auch uns überzeugt, dass keine Löcher in der Zelle sind und so weiter und so fort. Dann gucken wir uns vielleicht noch mal an, wie denn der Reifendruck ist, wie man das... Propeller. Soweit sind wir nicht. Jetzt laufen wir gerade rum. Jetzt machen wir erstmal vorne nochmal die Klappe über der Motorhaube auf sozusagen, über der Cowling. Da können wir dann den Ölstab rausziehen.
Über der was?
Cowling, das ist so die Motorhaube sozusagen.
Die Motorhaube heißt Cowling.
Das ist genauso wie Pits und Freudel bei einem Segel. Du könntest auch genau sagen, das ist der Waschlappen und der Eimer, aber das sagt halt keiner. So, jetzt gucken wir den Ölpeitschab ganz kritisch an. Gucken, ob da genug Öl drin ist. Hier haben wir auch unsere Vorgaben, wie viel da mindestens drin sein sollte.
Das ist ja wie beim Auto.
Genau.
Der Motor unterscheidet sich ja jetzt auch nicht wirklich.
Ja, im Detail schon, aber im Prinzip ist es... Im Prinzip meine ich.... sind da ganz befriedigt, stecken ihn wieder rein, machen die Klappe wieder zu und jetzt gucken wir uns den Propeller an. Fahrende mit der Hand mal lang, gucken, ob da keine großen Dellen drin sind. Das heißt, der Propeller ist ja auch ein aerodynamisches Wunderwerk und da wollen wir natürlich auch sicherstellen, dass diese Wunder auch schön seine Dienste verrichtet, damit es halt wie gesagt vorwärts geht. Dann gucken wir uns noch an. Ja, das Fahrwerk hatte ich glaube ich schon. Vorne natürlich auch nochmal. Dann Statik-Einlass hatte ich glaube ich auch schon.
Statik-Einlass?
Nein.
Was ist das?
Statik-Einlass? Ja, das waren die Röhrchen, die ich am Anfang erwähnt habe. Du hast das Pitot-Rohr, was für die Fahrtmessung da ist und dann brauchst du ja noch den Umgebungsluftdruck.
Wie heißt du dieses Rohr genannt?
Statik?
Nein, davor. Nein, danach.
Pitot-Rohr?
Pitot.
Pitot. P-I-T-O-T. Das ist für die Fahrtmesser.
Okay, das ist auch wieder so ein Name, den ich jetzt nicht hinterfragen darf. Das heißt einfach so.
Ja, das hängt jetzt wieder mit einem Herrn Pitot zusammen. Und da könnte man jetzt auch noch Ben Mully und alle möglichen anderen großen Physiker zitieren.
Nicht, dass wir jetzt einfach so Begriffe hier fallen lassen und davon ausgehen, dass jetzt jeder weiß, was gemeint ist, weil ich weiß auch nicht genau, was gemeint ist. Okay, also das Pitot-Rohr und was war das andere Rohr?
Das ist jetzt der Statik-Einlass. Da hast du einfach noch so ein ganz kleines Loch an der Seite. Und das ist einfach nur dafür da, um den Außendruck ans Instrument weiterzugeben, den du wieder brauchst für die Höhenmessung. So, jetzt haben wir aber eigentlich auch so mehr oder weniger alles durch. Sofern ich das jetzt mir im bewirrte in Gedächtnis habe, jetzt gehen wir einfach rein, schneiden uns schön an. Vorher haben wir natürlich unsere Ladung ordnungsgemäß verstaut, wissen also auch, wie der Schwerpunkt ist, haben genug Sprit an Bord, haben das alles brav ausgerechnet. Und dann können wir jetzt eigentlich mal anfangen.
Brav ausgerechnet heißt, man muss jetzt aber schon klar auch vor eine Ansage machen, wohin man will?
Na ja, Ansage machen in dem Sinne nicht, dass du jetzt der ganzen Welt erzählen musst, wo du denn hin willst. Aber zumindest du selbst sollst dir schon darüber klar sein, ok, wenn ich von A nach B möchte, das sind 500 Kilometer, ich habe aber nur 200 Kilometer Sprit an Bord, dass dann möglicherweise spätestens bei Kilometer 199 eine gewisse Unruhe im Cockpit auftritt.
Aber was hat man denn jetzt, also muss man vorher noch mal irgendwie Wetter-Check machen, ist man dazu verpflichtet, sollte man das tun, wird das eh gemacht?
Sowohl als auch. Also bei meinem Überland-Flug, also wenn ihr jetzt nicht mal einmal in den Flugplatz rumfliegen müsst...
Ja, sagen wir mal, wir fliegen jetzt von Berlin nach Hamburg.
Da haben wir schon zu Hause wahrscheinlich eine ordentliche Flugvorbereitung gemacht. Das heißt, wir haben uns überlegt, okay, in welcher Höhe will ich denn da hinfliegen, mit welchen Motorleistungen, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, ich verbrauche dann so und so viel im Steigflug, dann im Reiseflug, Rollen muss ich auch noch. Das heißt, da habe ich erstmal meinen Treibstoff verbraucht, dann weiß ich, okay, wie viele Leute will ich denn mitnehmen. Das heißt, wie viel Gewicht habe ich da, wie lange ist überhaupt die Start-Rollstrecke. Da kommen wir schon in die Details der Flugbahn.
Da muss man wirklich alles selber ausrechnen.
Das muss man alles selber ausrechnen. Aber das klingt jetzt wahrscheinlich komplizierter, als es wirklich ist. Wie bei allem hat man da irgendwann eine Routine drin.
Na gut, aber es macht ja schon mal einen deutlichen Unterschied, wenn ich jetzt beim Autolos fahre. Weil ich halt viel geladen habe, geht es halt langsamer, aber es ist jetzt nicht so überlebenswichtig.
Ja, beim Auto ist es halt auch nicht so, dass du irgendwie in deiner Straße hier losstattest und dann irgendwann gucken musst, hm, die Straße ist aber doch echt zu kurz für mich. Ich komme einfach nicht vom Fleck, ja. Und das ist ja auch das Tolle an so einem Flugzeug, das kann ja die tollsten Sachen machen. Ich meine, jeder kann mit so einer Cessna auf so einem Verkehrsflughafen mit zweieinhalbtausend Meter Piste starten und landen. Da kannst du mehrfach hintereinander starten und landen, ja. Aber spannend wird es dann ja, wenn du jetzt auf einem kleinen Bergflugplatz bist, wirklich eine kleine gemähte Wiese da vor dir hast. Die ist aber echt kurz. Und dann stell dir vor, jetzt hast du noch im Hochsommer, es ist richtig heiß, du bist richtig hoch. Was heißt das? Na, das mit der Luftdichte ist schon mal so ein Problem. Das heißt, du musst dann schon genau gucken, okay, reicht das denn noch? Na ja, die Luftdichte ist ja, also kalte, trockene Luft bietet dir die höchste Dichte, ist eigentlich zum Fliegen am besten. Und wenn du jetzt warme, feuchte Luft hast, ist eigentlich das Schlechteste. Da hast du eine niedrige Dichte, das heißt, da hast du auch nicht so viel Auftrieb und so weiter und so fort. Und das heißt zum Beispiel jetzt mal bei diesem konstruierten Beispiel, was gar nicht so konstruiert ist, an einem Hochsommertag, an einem ganz hochgelegenen Flugplatz mit einer ganz kurzen Piste vollbeladen zu starten, ist vielleicht gar keine so gute Idee.
Schon konstruiert, weil jetzt in Berlin einen hochgelegenen Flughafen zu finden, dürfte etwas schwierig sein. Na gut, okay, also das muss man auf jeden Fall mit einrechnen. Und bevor wir überhaupt schon soweit waren, dass wir am Flugplatz ankamen und uns irgendwie unser Flugzeug abgecheckt haben, müssen wir im Prinzip Planen machen und Dinge ausrechnen. Muss man dann auch noch Kartenmaterial dabei haben? Hat man das schon? Kriegt man das am Flughafen oder liegt das bei?
Du hast deine eigenen Karten, damit hast du ja deine Route geplant. Das ist eigentlich wie beim Segeln. Also wenn du auch mal gesegelt bist, kannst du das vorstellen. Da gibt es auch so eine Seekarte, da sagst du, okay...
Dann muss ich erst noch einen Podcast machen. Von Segeln habe ich auch keine Ahnung.
Okay, kommt später. Oder du steckst ja deinen Kurs ab, die und die Richtung, so und so viel Grad. Dann kannst du ja noch die... Das ist das Tolle, jetzt kommt noch die Wetterkomponente, da haben wir uns eigentlich auch noch darüber informiert. Im Wesentlichen ja, der Wind kommt von... Also angenommen, der Wind kommt von links, ja? Und ich will geradeaus fliegen, ja? Wenn ich dann geradeaus fliege, lande ich aber rechts, weil der Wind mich ja abtreibt. Also nehme ich einen sogenannten Vorhaltewinkel ein, fliege eigentlich so leicht nach links. Und dadurch, dass der Wind von links kommt, bin ich dann aber trotzdem geradeaus. So was will man dann auch vorher ausrechnen, damit man...
Das kostet dann auch mehr Sprit.
Na ja, wie immer hast du natürlich, wenn du Gegenwind hast, das ist wie beim Skaten, es ist immer ein bisschen anstrengender, als wenn du Rückenwind hast. Aber wenn du auf dem Hinflug Rückenwind hast oder Gegenwind, ist es ja dann meistens auf dem Rückflug genau andersrum. Insofern gleizt das dann häufig wieder aus.
Okay, na gut, aber auch das muss man jetzt für diese Spritberechnung durchaus mit aktuellen Daten einbauen. Man muss sich schon wirklich so den Abend vorher mal eine halbe Stunde hinsetzen und die Sache mal durchdenken.
Wetterdaten sind natürlich immer dann am besten, wie frisch und frischer sie sind. Also es geht ja nicht nur um Wind, es geht auch, was weiß ich, wenn dir da gerade so eine Kaltfront den Weg versperrt, überlegst du das vielleicht gerade mit so einer kleinen Chessner, ob du da wirklich direkt durchbrettern willst?
Gut, aber diese Vorbereitungszeit muss man jetzt dazu sagen. Die geht ja dann sozusagen von diesem Vergnügen schnell vor Ort zu sein und nur fünf Minuten Weg bis zur Maschine zu haben vom Auto, geht ja dann auch wieder ab. Also man muss jetzt sozusagen auch eine Vorbereitungszeit mit einrechnen. Das bleibt nicht aus. Halbe Stunde für einen erfahrenen Piloten ist das Alldeste.
Ja, das hängt halt von der Route ab.
Ja, wir bleiben jetzt mal beim Beispiel Berlin-Hamburg.
Ja, Berlin-Hamburg, je nachdem, wie viel Erfahrung du hast, hast du da sowieso alles. Angenommen, du hast deine Flugplanung im Computer. Heutzutage musst du ja auch nicht mal alles von Hand ausrechnen. Dann hast du da deinen...
Macht man das im Web oder hat man da so ein Programm?
Da hast du dann dein Programm. Da kannst du dir ein ganz einfaches Tabelle für benutzen. Na, du kannst jetzt Flugplanungssoftware verwenden. Gibt es von unterschiedlichen Herstellern. Du kannst aber auch ein einfaches Excel-Sheet benutzen, dass er das dann alles ausrechnet. Gibt es alles und erleichtert die Arbeit schon erheblich. Du kannst natürlich auch noch per Hand ausrechnen. Kann man problemlos machen, aber es geht halt einfach schneller.
Gibt es da so ein Microsoft Word der Flugplanung?
Ja, sowas gibt es, aber wie gesagt, da gibt es viele Hersteller. Das bekannteste ist sicherlich von Jefferson Flight Star, aber es gibt viele andere, die mindestens genauso gut sind. Also da gibt es jetzt keinen Grund, allgemein zu postulieren, das ist jetzt das Microsoft Word, das müssen alle benutzen.
Was benutzt du?
Ich benutze keine dieser ganzen Programme, ich habe mein kleines Excel-Sheet.
Du kalkulierst das einfach selber.
Das rechnet mir das da schnell aus.
Das hast du ja auch komplett selber entworfen oder gibt es da auch Vorlage?
Nein, da habe ich eine Vorlage verwendet, die das alles ganz wunderbar macht. Da trage ich nur die entscheidenden Daten ein und der Rest postuliert wunderschön raus. Und ich kann es mir direkt ausdrucken, dann habe ich direkt meinen Flugplan dabei, rechne mir auch aus, wie viel Sprit ich verbrauche und so. Also alles ganz wunderbar.
Das heißt, das haben wir jetzt vorher gemacht. Wir wissen Bescheid irgendwie, der Wind kommt von irgendwo. Und jetzt haben wir die Maschine gecheckt, haben uns angeschneit, klack, klack, was jetzt?
So, jetzt melden wir uns typischerweise mal im Funk und sagen erstmal Guten Tag. Flugzeug ABCD. Wir stehen da und dort. Wir planen jetzt mal zu rollen. Welche Frequenz? Die Frequenz des lokalen Flughafens.
Das heißt, die muss man vorher noch einstellen?
Ja, die muss man vorher einstellen. Jetzt ist natürlich auch wieder die Frage, die Frequenz des lokalen Flughafens. Das setzt sich wieder voraus, dass die nur eine Frequenz hat. Wenn ich jetzt natürlich an einem internationalen Verkehrsflughafen stehe, da habe ich dann wieder allein, bis ich in der Luft bin, habe ich dann schon mal x-Frequenzwechsel hinter mir, weil ich dann erstmal, was weiß ich, am Vorfeld bin, dann ruf ich von Vorfeld die Rollkontrolle. Von der Rollkontrolle werde ich dann übergeben an den Tower und so weiter und so fort. Aber wir bleiben jetzt mal beim kleinen Grasflugplatz. Da haben wir eine Frequenz. Und da könnten wir jetzt mal sagen, okay, erbitte Rollinformation. Dann sagt er mir erstmal, welche Piste in Betrieb ist. Also ob ich jetzt von links oder nach rechts auf der Piste starte, sozusagen. Das ist wiederum vom Wind abhängig. Ich will ja immer gegen den Wind starten. Und dann könnten wir fast schon losrollen. Natürlich habe ich das alles etwas wieder zu schnell gemacht, denn wir wollen natürlich auch den Motor anlassen.
Müssen wir dann noch irgendwas checken innen? Also ich meine, wir haben jetzt außen alles gecheckt. Müssen wir innen auch noch alles checken?
Müssen wir auf jeden Fall. Das können wir aber auf dem Weg tun, auf dem wir zur Piste rollen. Auf dem Weg können wir das eigentlich erledigen.
Wie läuft denn die Kommunikation mit dem Tower? Also mach mal.
Ja, es gibt jetzt, das fängt schon an. Tower ist ja auch so ein beliebtes Wort. Die allermeisten Flugplätze haben gar keinen Tower. Das ist eine sogenannte Infostelle. Und wie der Name schon sagt, da gibt es halt Informationen, mehr aber auch nichts. Das heißt, es gibt da auch keine Freigaben nach dem Motto, ich will jetzt starten, ja, du darfst jetzt starten. Das ist vollkommen in der Verantwortung des einzelnen Piloten. Und diese Infostelle gibt dir nur Informationen, wie zum Beispiel jetzt am Anfang.
Die sagen einem schon, dass da gerade einer landen will.
Das sagen sie schon, aber es ist deine eigene Verantwortung, auch dafür zu achten, dass du nicht in den Rhein fährst. Verstehe. Und jetzt in dem Fall haben sie jetzt mal gesagt, was heißt, die Piste 1.0, was auch immer ist, Betrieb. Das heißt, du weißt, in welche Lande Richtung da ist, du hättest aber auch genauso gut selber auf den Windsack gucken können, dann wirst du das auch selber...
Oder weiß ich die Lande Richtung?
Also wenn sie es dir nicht sagen, wenn du selber nachgucken willst, guckst du dir einfach auf den Windsack und dadurch ja gegen den Wind starten willst, siehst du dann direkt, okay, die Piste läuft von rechts nach links, der Wind kommt von links, also starte ich auch gegen den Wind.
Aber so eine Piste hat immer mehrere Bezeichnungen, je nachdem von welcher Seite man kommt, oder wie?
Exakt. Und zwar ist das immer die auf 2-Ziffern verkürzte Gradzahl. Also angenommen, du hast jetzt Piste 28, wäre dann 280 Grad, also sozusagen von Westen nach Osten verlaufend.
Oder 1,0 in die andere Richtung, 180 Grad sozusagen, also 18 Differenz.
Also das ist eigentlich ganz simpel. Und dann hast du natürlich jetzt einen großen Flugplatz und hast dann noch die, was weiß ich, 28 links und rechts, L und R. Im ganz, ganz großen Flugplatz hast du vielleicht noch C für Center, drei parallele Bahnen, selten. Und dann hast du vielleicht noch eine Startbahn West-Wien-Frankfurt, die in eine ganz andere Richtung geht, aber das ist jetzt schon wieder etwas.
Jaja, wir sind immer noch auf der Alm.
Genau.
Der Berliner Alm.
Genau, auf der Berliner Alm hören wir jetzt die Kuhglocken läuten.
Okay, aber wie läuft jetzt die Kommunikation mit der Infostelle? Also konkret jetzt?
Ja, konkret kann ich fragen hier Delta, Echo, Tango, India, Mike. Also Flugplatz Info, Delta, Echo, Tango, India, Mike. Positionen da und dort, meinetwegen an der Tankstelle. Erbitte Rollinformation für einen VFR-Flug nach wohin auch immer. VFR, Visual Flight Rules, Sichtflugregeln.
Das heißt, ohne Instrumente, wir gucken einfach selber aus dem Fenster, wir wissen schon, was wir tun.
Genau. Und dann sagt er dir vielleicht, ja, Delta, Echo, Tango, India, Mike. Wir haben die Piste beispielsweise 1.0 in Betrieb. Und Rollen geht deshalb darüber. So, das ist eigentlich schon mehr als du wirklich streng genommen nach den internationalen Regeln bräuchtest. Du kannst es auch, wenn du angenommen bist, hast du einen Wüstenflugplatz, ist sonst keiner da. Da ist keine Pflicht, dass du mit irgendjemand sprechen musst. Musst halt selber gucken. Geht auch. So, jetzt rollen wir dann zu dem Rollhaltepunkt von der richtigen Stelle der Bahn.
Wie rollen wir denn? Wir müssen noch den Motor anmachen.
Das haben wir jetzt schon gemacht.
Da warte ich ja die ganze Zeit drauf, dass wir den Motor anmachen. Dann kriegt das Ganze jetzt hier auch ein bisschen Ambienz. Also das Teil hat einen Anlass, oder? Die Chessler.
Ja, das ist schon mal ein ganz großer Luxus, elektrischer Anlass.
Das heißt, du drückst es auf den Knopf und dann macht es...
Ja, ja, jetzt haben wir natürlich noch das Gemisch vorher eingestellt und haben vielleicht vorher noch was eingespritzt und so weiter und so fort. Aber jetzt springt unser dicker, fetter Boxer-Motor an. Genau, gucken wir auf die Drehzahl, gucken wir auf die Öltemperatur. Das sollte sich dann alles in den berühmten grünen Bereichen reinbewegen. Und wenn das alles ist, wunderbar, dann stellen wir auf die Lederaufdrehzahl. Jetzt sind es 1000 Umdrehungen. Und danach stellen wir auch unsere ganze Elektrik ein, z.B. die Avionik. Das sind ja empfindliche Gerätchen, die wollen wir nicht unbedingt mit diesen hohen Spannungen während des Anlassvorgangs konfrontieren. die Elektrik schalten wir erst ein, nachdem der Motor schon läuft.
Ah, verstehe. Da gibt es sozusagen den Schalter für alles.
Ja, es gibt Avionik Master und dann kannst du natürlich alles nochmal einzeln einstellen und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, und jetzt rollen wir los.
Jetzt rollen wir los.
Und rollen heißt, es gibt Gas?
Ja, nicht zu viel, wohlgemerkt.
Aber alles wird ja sozusagen durch den Propeller gezogen.
Ja, wir rollen langsam.
Und was muss sie jetzt irgendwie ziehen und drücken? Also da gibt es da jetzt verschiedene, also gibt es da Gaspedal?
Gaspedal, in dem Sinne gibt es jetzt bei der Cessna nicht. Also es könnte jetzt ein Hebel sein. Bei den Cessnas ist es eigentlich so ein, wie soll ich sagen, so ein Ziehknopf sozusagen. Also wenn ich reindrücke, ist Gas und wenn ich ziehe, rausziehe, ist Gas weg. Dann haben wir außer dem Gas, den drückst du jetzt so leicht rein, dann gibt es Gas und dann rollen wir los um die Pumpe übers Gras. Wir haben jetzt zur Motorkontrolle auch noch das Gemisch, wo ich dann also fettes und reiches Gemisch, also das Luft-Kraftstoff-Gemisch manuell ändern kann. Da habe ich so eine Vergaservorheizung, dann hätte ich jetzt bei Flugzeugen, die etwas komplexer sind als die 172, wo es noch Vorstellpropeller gibt, habe ich noch einen weiteren Hebel, wo ich die Steigung des Propellers einsteigen kann. Aber das machen wir jetzt mal nicht so kompliziert. Wir rollen jetzt erstmal los und während wir zum Rollhalt rollen, machen wir schon unsere ganzen anderen Checks. Das heißt, wir drehen zweimal den Rudern, schauen dabei raus.
Ob sie sich auch wirklich drehen?
Ja, und drehen sie sich auch in die richtige Richtung. Das ist auch eine ganz wichtige Nebenfunktion. Angenommen, das war jetzt gerade in der Wartung und irgendjemand hat gepennt und sie leider falsch rum dran gemacht. Das wäre doch einfach blöd. Das würde überraschen, wenn du nach rechts abbiegen willst, sozusagen, und das Ding fliegt nach links ab. Das könnte dich verwirren.
Ja, oder man will nach oben und...
Alles unangenehm. Deswegen guckst du das alles nochmal an. Dann machst du vor Abflug auch nochmal einen sauberen Run-Up von dem Motor. Wir gehen davon aus, dass Motoröl mittlerweile warm ist. Das heißt, wir machen nochmal einen Leerlauf-Vollgas-Test. Dann probieren wir unsere Magneten aus. Die Zündmagneten. Das Tolle ist, der Flugzeug kann auch weiter fliegen, wenn einer der Zündmagnete ausfällt, weil wir noch einen zweiten haben. Deswegen gucken wir auch nach dem Drehzahlabfall. Das ist noch so klassisch. Nichts mit elektronischer Einspritzung usw. Das gibt es zwar mittlerweile auch, aber jetzt bei dem Modell, was wir uns hier gerade hypothetisch und virtuell vorstellen, gibt es noch richtig schöne Zündmagnete.
Wie funktioniert ein Zündmagnet? Aber ist auf magnetischer Basis?
Ja, du willst halt deine Zündfunken generieren. Das ist halt so richtig wie den 70ern im Wesentlichen. Also da hast du auch noch diese Vergaservorheizung. Das stellst du dir vor wie früher. Also da sind einfach so Elemente, die hast du natürlich beim modernen elektronisch gesteuerten Triebwerk nicht mehr. Aber wir haben jetzt ja noch so ein richtig schönes manuell gesteuertes Triebwerk, wo das alles noch dabei ist.
Die Wikipedia sagt, ein in der Zündspule durch Induktion erzeugter Stromfluss wird unterbrochen, wobei durch den Zusammenbruch des Magnetfeldes durch Selbstinduktion ein Hochspannungsimpuls erzeugt wird, der auf die Zündkerze geleitet wird.
Richtig, und so schön hätte ich es bestimmt nicht in einem Satz zusammenbringen können.
Okay, also bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt wusste ich gar nicht, also ist mir alles neu, wie auch immer. Keine Elektrik, sondern das fliegt alles von alleine.
Genau, das ist das Tolle, auch wenn dir halt mal das elektrische System komplett ausfallen würde, du kannst immer noch problemlos weiterfliegen, das ist gar kein Problem. Du kannst dann wahrscheinlich die elektrischen Klappen irgendwann nicht mehr ausfahren, musst du aber nicht, du kannst wahrscheinlich auch noch ohne die Klappen landen, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade eine ganz kurze Piste hast. Und funken kannst du halt auch nicht mehr, aber das Ding fliegt weiterhin weiter. Und auch ohne Strom läuft der Motor auch nach wie vor weiter, das ist schon mal ganz schön.
Also ohne Funk fliegen ist eigentlich nicht so erlaubt, oder?
Doch, doch, das ist alles möglich. Wie gesagt, die besagte Piper Cup hat ja gar kein elektrisches System, da kannst du gar nicht funken, da gibt es nämlich nichts. Das heißt, du kannst in bestimmte Lufträume natürlich nicht rein, also wenn du jetzt kontrolliert einen Luftraum, eine Kontrollzone um einen Verkehrsflughafen drumherum, da ist es schon extrem hilfreich, sich zu koordinieren. Und dann einfach mal so auf gut Glück da anzufliegen, das ist bei so einem komplexen Verkehrsfluss nicht möglich, da brauchst du ein Funkgerät.
Da kommt der Herr Schäuble und schießt einen ab.
Ja, der Herr Schäuble hat uns ja wahrscheinlich sowieso schon vorher durchleuchtet und hat schon vorausgesehen, dass wir solche Sturken sind und es uns schon vorher... Wie auch immer, aber grundsätzlich ist das jetzt kein stricktes Erfordernis, Funk an Bord zu haben. Aber es erleichtert die natürlich schon erheblich.
Na klar.
Mittlerweile stehen wir am Rollhalt von der Bahn.
Rollhalt?
Also wir sind noch nicht auf der Bahn selbst, weil wir möglicherweise noch andere Flugzeuge landen und starten. Wir stehen aber sozusagen am Ende der Bahn, wo wir eigentlich drauf wollen.
Also Rollfeld ist sozusagen der Bereich vor der Landebahn, Start- und Landebahn, oder?
Ja, wir reden jetzt mal von den Rollwegen. Es gibt also die Bahn, dann gibt es die Rollwege und dann gibt es noch das Vorfeld, was dann auch je nach Flugplatz sehr unterschiedliche räumliche Ausdehnung haben kann. Also wenn Tempelhof hast du dann so ein riesen Vorfeld, wo du also kilometerweise Flugzeuge abstellen kannst. Auf dem Beispielgrasplatz, von dem wir jetzt gerade reden, ist das ganz einfach möglicherweise direkt neben der Landebahn. Man stellt sich dann den Flugzeug ab, mit ein bisschen Abstand. Das ist also nicht so schrecklich kompliziert. Jetzt gehen wir auch davon aus, wir haben alle unsere ganzen Checks vor dem Abflug gemacht. Wir haben unser Briefing für uns selber runtergesagt und dann sind wir eigentlich abflugbereit.
Unser Briefing? Was heißt das? Dass wir uns selber nochmal verinnerlichen, wohin wir eigentlich wollen?
Und was wir eigentlich tun, wenn bestimmte unfähige Dinge auftreten und so weiter. Das ist einfach eine professionelle Methode. Testament. Das Schöne am Fliegen ist ja, was ich auch im Rahmen der Ausbildung sehr schätzen gelernt habe, ist, dass der Fokus auf Sicherheit wirklich sehr hoch ist. Und ich bin der festen Überzeugung, wenn man diese Kultur der Sicherheit, also Sicherheit ist einfach cool und unsicher fliegen ist uncool. Wenn man diese Sicherheitskultur schaffen würde, ist in der normalen Führerscheinausbildung auch durchzusetzen. Da hätten wir sehr viel weniger Unfälle. Das ist einfach wirklich, das ist wirklich schön. Und je mehr man das verinnerlicht, desto mehr lernt man das zu schätzen, dass es halt nicht einfach so naja, wird schon gehen, sondern nein. Das gucken wir jetzt mal genau. Und was weiß ich angenommen, wir machen jetzt nun mal ein Beispiel. Wir machen jetzt einen langen Flug über Wasser und haben nur einen Motor an Bord. Kann ich natürlich einfach nur so losfliegen. Ich kann aber auch mir das vorher ausrechnen und denken, also ich will jetzt mal nach Bornholme, nur mal hypothetisches Beispiel. Ja, da fliege ich ja längere Zeit über die Ostsee. Da sehe ich dann natürlich noch mal gar kein Land. Kann mir das aber so ausrechnen, dass ich genau in der Mitte, worst case jetzt, genau in der Mitte vom Festland, also genau in der Mitte über dem Meer zwischen den beiden Küsten, fällt mir der einzige Motor aus. Dann geht es ja tendenziell abwärts, aber glücklicherweise nicht so schnell. Diese Flugzeuge können ja segeln. Und jetzt kann ich mir natürlich die Höhe genauso vorher ausrechnen und wählen, dass selbst wenn mir im ungünstigen Fall der Motor genau in der Mitte ausfällt, ich immer noch im Gleitflug den nächsten Flugplatz erreichen kann. Das kann ich machen.
Solange hält das.
Und das ist einfach sicher.
Wenn man über die Ostsee fliegt.
Echt?
Wie hoch muss man denn da fliegen?
Das müsste ich jetzt noch mal genau ausrechnen, aber ich glaube, du kommst mit unter 10.000 Fuß aus. Also ich hatte das, habe es ja schon mal gemacht. Also ich müsste es mir jetzt auch noch mal ausrechnen, weiß nicht mehr, ob es gar nicht so hoch ist. Also je nach dem natürlich an welcher Stelle du drüber fliegst.
Jetzt muss ich das mal kurz übersetzen. 10.000 Fuß, 3.000 Meter, 3 Kilometer.
Und dann sinkst du mit 540.
Wie hoch kann man so fliegen mit so einem Teil?
Also mit der Cessna kommst du vielleicht so je nach dem, welchen Motor du da drin hast. Also wenn du jetzt keinen turboaufgeladenen Motor hast, sagen wir mal 12.000 Fuß, da ist dann normalerweise Schluss. Mit dem turboaufgeladenen Motor kommst du natürlich höher. Das ist das Interessante am Turbomotor. Beim Auto geht es ja, da ist es nur schneller. Aber das Tolle bei der Luftfahrt ist halt, der Turbomotor ermögst dir nicht einfach nur schneller zu fliegen, sondern vor allem die Dichte zu halten, auch wenn du ganz hoch bist. Das ist ja das Problem des normalen Saugmotors. Aber die Luft, die verbrennt ist natürlich. Genau. Und das ist das Tolle am Turbomotor beim Fliegen. Das möchte man eigentlich echt haben.
Das heißt, man verdichtet die Luft und wird dadurch unabhängig vom Luftdruck, der herrscht. Und umso höher man ist, umso niedriger ist natürlich der Luftdruck.
Und das ist natürlich eine tolle Sache.
Stimmt.
Und hat mehr Steigleistung und so weiter.
Und deswegen wollte ich über Fliegen reden. Okay, das heißt die Sicherheit. Okay, das heißt solche Dinge kriegt man in der Ausbildung. Aber zur Ausbildung können wir gleich noch mal kommen. Da wollte ich eh noch mal ein paar Sachen zu fragen. Vielleicht fliegen wir einfach mal los.
Genau, wir sagen jetzt noch, okay, wir rollen jetzt in die Bahn. Wir haben uns natürlich vorher überzeugt, dass wir dann nicht in irgendjemanden reinrollen.
Das sagen wir der Infostelle.
Das sagen wir der Infostelle und die hören dann ja auch alle anderen ab, die gerade auf den Flugplatz zu fliegen.
Das heißt, okay, es ist nur ein Shared Medium, alle benutzen dieselbe Frequenz. Das heißt, man muss, der ist jetzt auch nicht sozusagen gezwungen, alles zu relayen, sondern das ist so okay.
Ja, Delta, Echo, Tango in Jamaik. Wir rollen jetzt in die Piste 2.8 zum Start zum Beispiel. Ja, dann sagt der im Prinzip gar nichts. Dann wiederholt er vielleicht nochmal dein Rufzeichen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe doch Hollywood-Filme gesehen in meiner Kindheit, da sagen die doch immer Roger.
Wahlweise sagen die noch so.
Sagt da keiner Roger?
Ach, Roger ist so eine Sache, das kannst du sagen, wenn du zu viele Filme geguckt hast. Aber das ist eigentlich der Überflüssigen Filmwirt. Ja, das kannst du mit bestimmten Umständen sagen, aber das ist nicht so unbedingt notwendig. Also eines der eher überflüssigen Wörter. Da gibt es wenig Wichtige. Jetzt kann die Info-Stütze noch sagen, so schöne Füllsätze wie Start und Land nach eigenem Messen. Aber eigentlich ist sowieso klar, dass du auf einem unkontrollierten Flugplatz immer nach eigenem Messen startest und landest. Insofern ist das eine nette Sache. Ja, aber das ist eigentlich klar. Dann rollen wir in die Bahn, schieben das Gas rein. Wir haben natürlich vorher noch die Klappen entsprechend gesetzt. In dem Fall setzen wir sie jetzt mal auf 10 Grad, damit wir schön viel Auftrieb haben. Und dann rucken wir über die Graspiste und heben danach.
Die Klappen sind wo?
Hinten am Flügel.
Hinten an den großen Flügeln.
Genau, das heißt, die Klappen nach unten. Ja, vor allem klappen sie nach hinten. Also nach unten und nach hinten. Das heißt, die Flügelfläche wird vergrößert. Dadurch mehr Auftrieb. Dann geht's los. Dann heben wir ab. Wir kontrollieren natürlich nicht immer unsere Geschwindigkeiten.
Dann heben wir ab. Na, du bist gut. Also ich weiß noch, als wir das erst mal auf diesem Grasflugzeug... Also es gab nur einen Film, an den ich in dem Moment gedacht habe. Und zwar Bernhard und Bianca. Ja, wie Albatross Airlines und wie das Ding über diese Graspiste huckelte und humpelte und sprang und hoppste. Ich dachte nur, das kann doch jetzt wohl nicht wahr sein. Ich bin im Film und zwar genau in dem Film, wo dieses Mäusepärchen in der Sardinendose auf diesen Albatross geschnallt war. Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, ich weiß nicht genau, was ich gedacht habe, aber ich war auf jeden Fall schwer überrascht, dass das überhaupt noch alles unter Kontrolle zu halten ist. Aber das Erstaunliche ist ja, dass diese Dinger einfach eine frappierende Eigenstabilität aufweisen. Also ich habe danach meine, also ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich jemals unter Flugangst gelitten habe, aber es ging mir schon so, na ja, wenn man so landet, ein Flugzeug, und dann diese Luftlöcher, und dann wie geht das, wie so ein bisschen wackeliger, dann denkt man immer so, mein Gott, so wie das Ding hin und her wackelt, das müsste ja gleich kippen, so nach links um. Aber das kann eigentlich gar nicht passieren, oder?
Ja, du hast ja, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade in einem Eurofighter unterwegs bist, der eben nicht aerodynamisch stabil ist, also wo du auch halt einen Computer brauchst, um das ganze Ding überhaupt zu steuern, diese, gerade so eine Chesa, ich meine, die ist wirklich robust, unkaputtbar und halt sehr stabil. Das heißt, wenn du die Maschine voll richtig ausgetrimmt hast und einfach das Ruder mal loslässt, fliegt das einfach geradeaus, ja.
Was heißt getrimmt?
Trimmen heißt, du kannst diese ganzen Ruder noch mal mit so einem kleinen Rädchen einstellen. Also wir nehmen jetzt mal typische Trimmungen, das ist erstmal vor allem die, wo du praktisch das Höhenruder noch mal ein bisschen einstellst, damit du auch geradeaus fliegst und nicht runter oder höher. Das heißt, du stellst erstmal eine bestimmte Leistung am Motor ein.
Also so eine Kalibration auf Mittelwert.
Genau, ja. Und dann, wenn du jetzt das Ruder loslässt, also die Kontrollelemente loslässt und wir natürlich ruhige Luft haben, dann fliegt das Ding einfach mal geradeaus.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt so irgendwie schön und irgendwo in unseren 10.000 Fuß unterwegs sind oder weniger, man lässt einfach alles los und dann fliegt das Teil einfach, dann fliegt das Ding einfach.
Genau.
Einfach so geradeaus dahin, wo man irgendwie möchte. Und das ist genau das, was es tut. Man muss genau null Interaktionen betreiben mit dem Teil.
So ist das. Ich meine, man sollte natürlich die Hände, wie beim Autofahren auch am Steuer behalten. Es könnte ja mal irgendwas Unvorhergesehenes passieren. Aber vom Prinzip her ist das genauso.
Toll.
Ja, das ist wirklich entspannend. Das ist das Schöne am Fliegen halt, also eine der vielen wunderschönen Dinge am Fliegen. Gerade wenn du nach Sichtflug regel unterwegs bist, da bist du ja dein eigener Herr und hast dir deine eigene Route überlegt, fliegst du einfach lang und kannst einfach die Landwirtschaft unter dir genießen. Und du hast halt nicht das Problem, wie beim Autofahren. Also jetzt möchtest du mal flick fix unterwegs sein und die linke Spur sind die ganzen Idioten und auf der rechten Spur sind nur die ganzen Lastwagen. Das Problem hast du einfach nicht.
Oder wie im Verkehrsflugzeug, das irgendwie vor jedem Start, der erst mal fünf Minuten lang erzählt wird, wo die Ausgänge sind und wie du deinen Gurt anschnallen sollst. Aber es kommen auch keine Sauerstoffmasten von oben runtergefallen.
Die brauchen wir auch nicht, weil wir auch gar keinen Druckabfall haben können, weil wir ja gar keine Druckkabine haben in diesem Flugzeug.
Sondern da kann man einfach Fenster aufmachen und rausgucken. Ist auch ein bisschen laut, aber geht. Und dann kann man schön fotografieren, wenn man in der Lage ist, seine Kamera festzulügen.
Ja, und das macht ja Spaß. Also du hast ja wirklich ein sehr unmittelbares, ich sag ja immer, das mag zwar widersprüchlich klingen, aber eigentlich hast du ein sehr unmittelbares Naturerlebnis, weil du da die Landschaft unter dir herziehst. Du siehst wirklich, wie auch die Landschaft aufgebaut ist. Flussbetten, die sich tief eingefräst haben, Berglandschaften, also auch Mittelgebirge. Die nimmt man ja sonst so mit dem Auto vielleicht irgendwie wahr, dass man da irgendwie durch so ein Mittelgebirge fährt. Aber wenn du das wirklich da so siehst, zum Beispiel den Harz, ist ja immer so eine schöne...
Das ist wie Google Earth, bloß mit einem besseren Farbabgleich.
Ja, und vor allem mit viel besseren Texturen, ja.
Aber vielleicht noch mal kurz zum Start. Also was musst du denn dann machen beim Start? Also du stehst jetzt irgendwie auf dieser Bahn, jetzt schiebst du den Hebel rein, das heißt, der Propeller macht völlig thermik. Wir hatten vorher die Klappen ausgefahren und jetzt gibt man eigentlich nur noch Gas und lenkt geradeaus und irgendwann geht das Ding automatisch in die Luft oder muss man dann noch irgendwas tun? Gibt es so einen Zeitpunkt, wo man noch irgendwie so eine Reißleine ziehen muss?
Du hast es gerade auch richtig zusammengefasst. Der Punkt ist nur, was du außerdem noch tust, was du jetzt nicht siehst als Passagier, aber was du halt als Pilot tust, du guckst ständig, ob auch alles im grünen Bereich ist. Also ich habe ja eine Vorstellung, ab welcher Geschwindigkeit das Ding abheben soll. Ich habe auch eine Vorstellung davon, nach wie vielen Metern das abheben sollte. Und wenn das nicht eintrifft, dann mache ich einen Startabbruch.
Ohne jetzt erst mal groß darüber nachzudenken, wie man das beheben könnte, sondern man lässt einfach sein.
Also wenn ihr... Hattest du das schon mal? Ja, das hatte ich schon mal.
Und was war dann die Ursache?
In dem Fall war die Ursache, dass das Flugzeug längere Zeit draußen stand, ohne einen Pitoro-Schutz. Also normalerweise hast du diese kleinen, schönen roten Fleckchen mit einem Schnupsi vorne dran, wo drauf steht, remove before flight, immer sehr gern gesehen. Die lienen dazu, diese ganzen Rohre abzudecken. Das war jetzt nicht abgedeckt. Das haben wir hinterher herausgefunden. Da hatte sich im Hochsommer ein Insekt mal in dieses Pitoro rein verirrt. Als es dann losging, kam es natürlich nicht mehr raus, weil da natürlich echt viel Luft in die falsche Richtung drückte. Dadurch hatte ich keine Fahrtmesse-Anzeige.
Du hast gesehen, dass der Speed nicht richtig angezeigt wird, und dann hast du gesagt, das geht ja gar nicht. Du hättest wahrscheinlich trotzdem starten können.
Du hättest problemlos, du kannst auch ohne Fahrtmesse natürlich starten. Aber das ist halt alles nicht so toll. Ja, ist ein lustiges Beispiel.
Das sind so die Real-Life-Varianten. Aber an sich, das Ding hebt einfach von leiner ab.
Und außen hab ich natürlich meine Geschwindigkeiten. Ich sag jetzt, okay, Airspeed, Alive. Und dann weiß ich jetzt, okay, jetzt geht's los. Und das ist jetzt die richtige Geschwindigkeit. Und alles Steigwinkel passt und so weiter und so fort.
Dann schließt das Teil einfach nach oben. Und wie hoch muss man dann... Also Sichtflug heißt ja, dass ich... Also vollständig, alle meine ganze Navigation beruht da drauf, was ich so sehe. Und wenn da irgendwo ein anderes Flugzeug ist, dann muss ich einfach selber dafür sorgen, dass ich halt nicht so hoch, also nicht auf derselben Höhe bin. Kann ich mit dem denn funken? Also ist irgendwie klar, auf welcher Frequenz? Also gibt es da so einen Chatten in den Wolken?
Es gibt so eine Art Chat in den Wolken, das nennt sich Fluginformationsdienst für VFRs, also für den Sichtflug, wo man sich anmelden kann. Und dann hörst du halt auch immer, was weiß ich, der X ist da gerade von links nach rechts unterwegs. Und vor allem, selbst wenn der X sich nicht angemeldet hat, er muss es nämlich nicht, sagt er dir, wenn du halt vorher die Infostelle darum gebeten hast, dir doch mal Verkehrsinformationen durchzugeben, sagt er dir jetzt, pass mal auf, jetzt kommt er von links nach rechts, sozusagen so und so viel Grad, kommt ihnen in der gleichen Flughöhe was entgegen. Schauen sie mal raus. Und wenn der dann weiß, welches das ist, kann er auch sagen, da kommt, was weiß ich, eine Piper oder eine andere Chest oder was auch immer entgegen, so und so viel Höhe. Und dann weißt du das schon mal. Das ist also eine Entlastung.
Das heißt, so eine Infostelle gibt es auch für jeden Bereich, wo man fliegen kann in Deutschland. Oder generell weltweit? Oder reden wir jetzt von Deutschland?
Also generell weltweit gibt es das schon, nur gibt es natürlich wie immer Gegenden, wo es das halt nicht gibt, wo es keine Radarabdeckung gibt und so und so fort. Aber vom Prinzip her kann es mal davon ausgehen, sowas gibt es eigentlich überall. Bis auf, wie gesagt, natürlich die total verlassenen Gäste.
Das steht dann auf meiner Karte.
Die Frequenz meinst du? Ja, die steht da drauf.
Das heißt, ich muss dann mal so klack, klack, klack, klack, klack machen irgendwie. Dann gehe ich auf die Frequenz und dann darf mal Hallo-Info-Stelle. Ich blicke jetzt hier übrigens gerade lang und ich bin auf in Richtung, hm, unterwegs.
Ja, lang genug. Wir sind hier in Berlin gestartet. Ja, dann oder in Brandenburg. Ähm, sind wir gerade erst mal, haben wir erst mal die Höhe gefahren. Jetzt ab ein paar hundert, 400 Fuß fahren wir jetzt die Klappen wieder ein, ne. Ähm, suchen uns dann unsere Reiseflughöhe. Äh, und dann machen wir mal schön das Flugzeug austrimmen. Wie gesagt, dann machen wir wieder geradeaus. Und dann haben wir bis jetzt immer Vollgas. Jetzt drehen wir mal auf Reisefluggeschwindigkeit runter. Das heißt, auch Gas wird eingestellt, Gemisch wird eingestellt. Und dann fliegen wir gemütlich in die eine Richtung. Und dann können wir dann auch hier die Frequenzen wechseln und sagen, hallo, sowieso von da nach da. Wenn wir das jetzt wollen, ne, und das ist also im Prinzip eine empfehlenswerte Geschichte, ähm, wir bitten verkehrsinformationen. Und dann, wenn der jetzt nicht komplett überlastet ist und immer wieder gerade Sonntag ist, dann sagt er dir ja, kein Problem, ich sag hinter Bescheid, ne.
Ach, Sonntag ist alles voll mit Sonntagsfliegern. Dann ist richtig thermig. Dann ist richtig was los.
So ist das.
Da muss man auch mal richtig gucken.
Ja, richtig gucken muss man immer, ja. Aber es gibt halt natürlich, wie immer, was weiß ich, genauso wie wenn du mit der Bahn jetzt, ähm, an die Ostsee fahren willst an einem wunderschönen Sommerwochenende, ist natürlich auch so, dass an einem wunderschönen Sommerwochenende auch entsprechend viele Leute an die Ostsee fliegen wollen. Und speziell in der Umgebung der Flugplätze heißt da natürlich immer Augen auf im Straßenverkehr.
Aber als wir da unterwegs waren, kann ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass da irgendwie so viele andere Flugzeuge im Kreuz waren.
Ja, es ist halt auch relativ immer weniger und es ist halt echt viel Luft da um einen drum herum. Aber geguckt wird halt trotzdem.
Ja, klar. Was ich auch ganz interessant fand, ist gerade jetzt hier im, also ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Phänomen von Brandenburg ist, kannst du mir ja gleich mal sagen. Neben den ganzen Seen und Wäldern, Burgen und Flüssen und was man da alles so sieht, gab es auch eine ganze Menge Flugplätze. Von oben sieht man das ja auch, wie viele gibt es inheitlich.
Also frag mich nicht nach einer konkreten Zahl, aber sind das überall so viele wie hier?
Oder ist das jetzt so ein Brandenburger Phänomen?
Also es ist, wenn wir jetzt mal auf das Mitteleuropa einschränken, kann man einfach sagen, es gibt wirklich viele und viel, viel, viel mehr als so der normale Bürger denkt. Also weil ja Flugplatz, der normale Bürger denkt halt immer gleich, ein Flugplatz, das ist so ein Verkehrsflughafen mit X-Runways, mit einem Tower. Dieser Tower ist ja halt auch eine total fakultative Geschichte eigentlich. Und da gibt es halt in jeder Großstadt vielleicht einen. Es gibt aber halt unglaublich viele kleine Plätze. Wirklich, das sind die letzten Äcker mitten in der Pampa. Und du kommst in Mitteleuropa erstaunlich nahe an jeden beliebigen Platz mit einem kleinen Flugplatz dran. Das ist dann vielleicht nur eine Graspiste, wie gesagt, mit einer kleinen Hütte daneben. Aber das ist ja vollkommen ausreichend. Wenn du jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie bei Sicht 0 einen vollautomisierten Instrumentenlandeanflug nach Kategorie 3b durchführen willst, ist das ja kein Problem. Da kannst du ja nach Sichtflug auch auf einem kleinen Acker landen. Da gibt es eine sehr hohe Dichte an Flugplätzen. Das ist eine ganz wertvolle Infrastruktur, die auch für viele Gebiete wirklich auch eine entscheidende Rolle spielt. Nehmen wir mal die Nordsee-Inseln zum Beispiel. Die haben alle ihren kleinen Flugplatz.
Ich glaube, dein GSM-Telefon ist gerade am Stören. Sollen wir es mal vom Kabel irgendwie wegnehmen? Oder man hört das eh gleich auf. Ah, da hinten ist es. Ich, da stört das noch. GSM ist echt furchtbar.
Und diese Nordseeinseln haben alle ihren kleinen Flugplatz. Und der ist, wie gesagt, essentiell, wenn mal zum Beispiel, sag ich mal, die Fahrrinne ist vereist, mit der normalerweise die Fähre kommt. Oder du musst mal ganz dringend einen Patienten ausfliegen, aus Festland, und leider ist gerade mal die Ebbe nicht da oder die Flut bzw. nicht da, die du brauchst, um rüberzukommen. Dann kannst du mal kurz mit dem Flugzeug rüber. Das sind also richtige Lebensadern teilweise. Oder zumindest lebenswichtige Backups für solche Fälle. Und das natürlich in Gegenden, wo jetzt die noch ländlicher sind, also speziell in Nordamerika, wo du riesige Distanzen hast, noch viel, viel essenzialer. Und es ist wirklich faszinierend, was es da eine Infrastruktur in Deutschland und Europa gibt. Es ist wirklich schön.
Also, das heißt, meine Wahrnehmung, dass es jetzt in Brandenburg besonders viele Flugplätze gibt, stimmt nicht. Es gibt überall genauso viele.
Was du in Brandenburg hast, ist natürlich, was als ein lokales Phänomen ist, die vielen ehemaligen russischen Flugplätze.
Genau, das war es, die unglaublich vielen, unglaublich großen Flughäfen. Man hat ja das Gefühl, die ganze Zeit über, was weiß ich, Monstern an Flughäfen zu fliegen.
Ja, das ist sicherlich ein spezielles Charakteristikum von Brandenburg, wo du das nicht so findest. Da hast du einfach riesengroße Flughäfen.
Ich weiß ja wieder, warum mir das noch so in Erinnerung gebitten ist.
Mit ewig langen Pisten, Beton, riesig viele Bunker drum herum, die dann natürlich heute alles nicht mehr so in dem Ummaß...
Da könnte man mal eben so einen Airbus A380 starten und landen.
Ja, A380 vielleicht vom Gewicht her nicht unbedingt, aber so vom Prinzip her...
Von der Länge her wird es reichen, ja. Weil die da immer ihre schweren Transportmaschinen hoch und runter kriegen.
Ja, oder auch die Kampfflugzeuge, die ja da vor allem auch stationiert waren, die haben natürlich genau dieses Problem, was ich ganz am Anfang mal erwähnte, mit entweder schnell oder langsam fliegen. Es gibt nur wenige Flugzeuge, die das beides hinkriegen. So ein Kampfflugzeug soll ja möglichst schnell dem Feind entgegenfliegen. Jetzt ist natürlich das Problem, wenn das Ding landen will, ist es halt echt schnell im Landeanflug. Also so ein ordentliches Kampfflugzeug fliegt halt deutlich schneller im Landeanflug. Also wenn es die niedrigste Geschwindigkeit hat, wo es überhaupt noch in der Luft ist, ist das schon noch deutlich schneller, als ich überhaupt mit der Höchstgeschwindigkeit in meiner kleinen Cessna jetzt mit dir unterwegs bin. Das heißt, die brauchen eine entsprechend lange Piste, um einfach nur auszuräumen.
Das heißt, die landen mit 600 Sachen oder was?
Ja, das ist nicht mit 600 Sachen, aber schon deutlich, deutlich, deutlich schneller, als wir überhaupt im Reiseflug fliegen.
Ist das nicht so der Reiseflug? Entschuldigung, ich bin jetzt schon wieder bei Stundenkilometern.
Du rechnest wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Knoten. Ja, aber unsere Reisegeschwindigkeit ist jetzt vielleicht in Kilometern umgerechnet jetzt vielleicht 220 Kilometer pro Stunde. Also das ist schneller, als man denkt, im Vergleich zum Auto, weil man ja beim Auto niemals 220 kmh als Dauergeschwindigkeit hat. Aber für ein Flugzeug ist das verhältnismäßig langsam.
Das heißt, diese Kampfflieger, die kommen dann mit?
Die kommen dann vielleicht mit 200, 300 kmh an. Langsam zu Geschwindigkeiten. Also eher 300.
Und wenn wir jetzt mit der Kleinen landen, wie schnell sind wir dann in dem Moment, wo die Räder aufsetzen?
Also wir können die Anfluggeschwindigkeit, also wir wollen ja noch fliegen, also so viel aufsetzen, brauchen wir ja nicht mehr Geschwindigkeit, aber solange wir noch fliegen wollen, sind wir bei der Chesa so typischerweise bei 60 Knoten. Das ist jetzt je nach Flugzeugtyp wieder unterschiedlich, deswegen sollte man da jetzt da keine allgemeine Zahlen, das ist wieder die Kunst des Designs. Man will natürlich eine möglichst niedrige Geschwindigkeit haben, also eine möglichst niedrige Geschwindigkeit.
60 Knoten, 111 Stundenkilometer, also sozusagen die Hälfte. Also die Hälfte der Höchstgeschwindigkeit oder der normalen Reisegeschwindigkeit, das ist so das, was man so nicht unterschreiten sollte.
Ja, so allgemein kann man es wieder nicht sagen, das ist halt je nach Flugzeug unterschiedlich.
Ja klar, ich will jetzt nur mal diesem Beispiel bleiben und irgendeine Vorstellung sagen, das wird ja jetzt auch, was weiß ich, ein Viertel oder 10 Prozent.
Das Ding kann sogar noch langsamer fliegen, das ist total faszinierend, sollte man, das ist aber nicht die geplante Anfluggeschwindigkeit, aber es ist total faszinierend, wenn du das mal wirklich hübst nach dem Motto, was ist denn jetzt, wie kriege ich das Ding jetzt wirklich zum, wie kriege ich den wirklichen Strömungsabriss hin? Und wie fühlt sich das dann an, wie recover ich, also wie komme ich aus dieser Situation wieder raus, das machst du ja immer als Training. Und das ist wirklich faszinierend, wie langsam dieses Flugzeug fliegen kannst. Du fliegst dann einfach mal nach oben, damit es immer langsamer wird. Und das ist wirklich faszinierend, du denkst wirklich, gleich stehen wir. Das ist wirklich, also das ist auch das Faszinierende an diesen einfachen, robusten Flugzeugen, wie langsam die fliegen können. Das ist schon, es ist wirklich...
Das heißt, der wichtige Strömungsabriss findet erst sehr viel später statt.
Ja, du willst ja immer ein deutliches Polster da drüber haben.
Vielleicht noch mal so ein Fall, der mir gerade einfiel, weil du ja auch schon gesagt hast, Sonderzonen, also man darf ja nicht überall fliegen. Also man darf, oder weiß ich nicht, darf man überall fliegen? Wo darf man fliegen?
Sagen wir mal so, also Gebiete, in denen du überhaupt gar nicht fliegen darfst unter gar keinen Umständen, das sind sehr, sehr wenige.
Das ist dann so militärisches Sperrgebiet?
Ja, selbst diese Sperrgebiete sind in meistens nur Flugbeschränkungsgebiete. Das mag jetzt Wort nach Wortklauerei klingen, aber da gibt es halt einen Unterschied. Die sind halt beispielsweise, kannst du eine Durchflugfreigabe bekommen, wenn du höflich fragst, möglicherweise. Oder die sind nur zu bestimmten Zeiten aktiv, was in der Regel der Fall ist und so weiter und so fort. Also richtige Sperrgebiete gibt es in Deutschland, wenn ich mich nicht irre, gar keine. Das sind immer nur Flugbeschränkungsgebiete. Die sind dann aber die meiste Zeit aktiv, das heißt, sie ähneln dann wieder Sperrgebieten. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es wirklich ganz wenige Gegenden, wo du gar nicht fliegen darfst. Jetzt ist die Frage, mit welchem Aufwand du bestimmte Gegenden durchreisen kannst. Das ist wieder ein anderes Thema. Mit unserem kleinen Sichtfliegerflugzeug sind wir bis zu einer Höhe von 10.000 Fuß wirklich sehr autonom. Wir können uns eigentlich unsere Route aussuchen, wo wir lang fliegen, und die Höhe können wir uns weitgehend aussuchen. Das ist alles unsere eigene Entscheidung. Wenn wir jetzt natürlich in eine Kontrollzone einfliegen, um einen großen Verkehrsflugplatz, wie wir das zum Beispiel hatten mit Tegel, zum Beispiel, oder wenn wir jetzt in bestimmte Lufträume einfliegen, die typisch um solche großen Verkehrsflughäfen angelegt sind, also kontrolliert Luftraum, dann müssen wir uns mit der Flugsicherung abstimmen. Dann ist auch Schluss mit Info-Service, dann hast du wirklich Flugführung, also die geben dir dann auch Anweisungen, je nach Szenario, in unterschiedlichem Maße, je nachdem, in welchem Luftraum du dich befindest. Und da heißt es dann auch, deine Absichten kommunizieren und entsprechend Anweisungen folgen. Aber jetzt, wenn wir mal das ganze Thema außen vor lassen, so im normalen Luftraum unter 10.000 Fuß bist du wirklich sehr frei.
Und was, ich kann mich noch erinnern, als wir irgendwie auf Tegel zugeflogen sind, da hatten wir das Problem, wir wollten einfach diesen Start- und Landebahnbereich quasi passieren. Und das ist ja, sagen wir mal, da ist ja auch in den 3.000 Metern, kann man ja schon noch irgendwas erwischen. Das heißt, man muss explizit sagen, ich will jetzt hier rüberfliegen, bitte sag mir Bescheid, wenn ich rüberfliegen darf.
Ja, in dem Fall waren wir auch noch deutlich niedriger als, als 3.000, das war ja unter 2.000 Fuß, also sehr, sehr niedrig. So eine Landebahn eines Verkehrsflughafens, da ist ja gerade in Tegel, da ist ja genug Action. Das heißt, wie quere ich die jetzt? Natürlich immer quer zur eigentlichen Start- und Lande-Richtung. Das heißt, im Fall von Tegel verläuft die Bahn jetzt von West nach Ost, bzw. Ost nach West. Das heißt, wir queren schön von Süd nach Nord. Und zwar genau in der Mitte, das sogenannte Midfield Crossing, weil da ja jedes Start- und Landendeflugzeug eigentlich noch am Boden sein sollte, oder schon am Boden sein sollte. Das ist also der sicherste Ort, um so einen Flugplatz zu queren. Jetzt ist da natürlich viel Action, Anflugverkehr usw. Es ist eine Kontrollzone, deswegen haben wir uns vorher angewältigt, gesagt, wir möchten Midfield Crossing machen von Süd nach Nord und dann weiter zum Kontrollpunkt sowieso. Das heißt, es gibt klare Kommunikation der Absichten.
Woran sprechen wir Englisch?
Ähm, es wäre jetzt in Tegel beides zulässig, aber als guten Stil an einem Verkehrsflughafen würde ich eigentlich Englisch sprechen, weil es ja auch Piloten gibt, die da anfliegen, die möglicherweise kein Deutsch sprechen.
Und die ja dann mithören, dasselbe Frequenz ist das gleiche Spiel wieder.
Die kriegen dann zwar vom Tower, in dem wir in diesem Fall Kontakt haben, auch gesagt, wenn irgendwas ist, was sie da gerade möglicherweise beachten müssen. Aber zur besseren situational awareness, sagt man auf Englisch, sagt man auf Deutsch, zur besseren Vergegenwärtigung der Situation ist natürlich gut, wenn alle verstehen, was im Funk gesprochen wird. Und es gibt bestimmte Lufträume, also über 10.000 Fuß, da ist Englisch vorgeschrieben, da ist der Schluss mit Deutsch.
Ah ja, verstehe. Da müssen dann irgendwie alle weltweit Englisch sprechen.
Genau.
Muss man auch einen Englisch-Test ablegen oder muss man nur so die Fachbegriffe können?
Ja, da gibt es jetzt wieder neue Regeln. Also du hast natürlich grundsätzlich mal, wenn du also ein Sprechfunkzeugnis kannst, du einfach nur ein Deutsches ablegen, dann bist du aber halt, bei Flügen im Ausland dann auch erstmal aufgeschmissen, da ist nämlich der Schluss. Und wenn du dann ein Sprechfunkzeugnis an die höheren Klassen ablegst, dann gehört da auch eine gewisse Englischprüfung automatisch mit dazu.
Und das ist ja nicht nur so, dass man jetzt so die Fachbegriffe runterrassert, sondern man muss sozusagen schon richtig so sprechen können. Man muss sich mit denen irgendwie...
Ja, du machst natürlich da keine Prosa und verfasst da keine Romane. Im Wesentlichen gibt es da schon eine recht festgelegte Terminologie. Die musst du halt drauf haben und dann musst du da halt bestimmte, unvorhergesehen Ereignisse ordentlich kommunizieren können. Das ist jetzt nicht so schrecklich komplex. Also es gibt genug Leute, die jetzt nicht ihr Lebenswerk auf Englisch verfassen, die trotzdem ganz problemlos Englisch funken können.
Also jetzt gibt es ja hier gerade in Berlin diese Diskussion mit den neuen Flughäfen. Es wird jetzt ein neuer großer Verkehrsflughafen gebaut, der BBI Berlin Brandenburg International, der irgendwie 2011 oder so in Betrieb gehen soll, oder?
Soll ist ein schönes Wort.
Es gibt Leute, die nennen dieses Datum, ich glaube, das ist das richtige, ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
2012 ist auch ein Sprich.
In dem Zusammenhang sollen Tegel und Tempelhof geschlossen werden. Tegel, denke ich mal, ist vielen bekannt, aber was so ein besonderes Unikum ist, ist halt Tempelhof. Das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig sehe, der erste wirkliche Flughafen gewesen, der überhaupt als solcher gebaut wurde auf diesem Planeten.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen. Der erste Flugplatz ist erstmal der Hügel, von dem Lillital gesprungen ist, im Zweifelsfall. Und dann den ersten Motorflugplatz, der liegt da in den Dünen in den USA, wo die Gebrüder auf Reit geflogen sind. Aber auf jeden Fall hat der Tempelhof für Deutschland eine ganz erhebliche historische Signifikanz. Ich meine, der Flugbetrieb am Tempelhofer Feld hat ja auch ganz einfach angefangen. Das war ja ein großer Exerzierplatz im Prinzip, also ein Übungsgebiet. Und damals gab es auch noch keine fest angelegten Landebahnen. Ganz am Anfang der Fliegerei hat man sich ja immer gedacht, wir wollen ja immer gegen den Wind starten. Das heißt, wir machen jetzt nicht nur eine Piste entlang der Hauptwindrichtung, wie wir das heutzutage eigentlich normalerweise überall haben, sondern wir haben halt sozusagen einen großen Kreis und starten halt immer genau gegen den Wind. Das heißt, wir stellen uns genau da auf, wo wir gegen den Wind starten. Eigentlich eine prima Idee, nur wird es halt sehr komplex zu koordinieren, wenn da halt richtig viel Flugverkehr ist. Deswegen das auf Dauer dann nicht durch.
Das ist der Grund, warum das Tempelhofer-Feld so ein großer Kreis ist sozusagen. Weil das ist ja so ein großer, mehr oder weniger runder...
Ja, die jetzige Form hat natürlich mit der ursprünglichen Form des Exerzierfeldes nicht mehr so viel zu tun. Aber im Grunde genommen kannst du wirklich sagen, früher war diese Fläche, auf der geflogen wird und in den Frühzeiten der Fliegerei war wirklich einfach eine große Fläche ohne irgendwelche Pisten. Da ging es einfach immer gegen den Wind los. Und da hat es dann noch eine Holzbaracke daneben. Und das war es dann. Und das, was heute da steht, ist natürlich ein ganz außergewöhnliches, ein ganz außergewöhnliches Verkehrsanlage und auch ein ganz außergewöhnlicher Bau, hast du selber schon gesagt. Ich zitiere immer gerne Norman Foster, den berühmten Architekten, der gesagt hat, Tempelhof ist eigentlich die Mutter aller Flughäfen. Und da ist einfach schon was dran. Das war zu seiner Zeit unerhört modern und kühn, mit diesen großen ausladenden Dächern auf das Vorfeld. Du konntest praktisch aus dem Flugzeug aussteigen und dann trockenen Fußes in das Empfangsgebäude gehen. Wenn du die anderen Wege nimmst, kommst du in dieses Empfangsgebäude rein, wirst von einer Glorie des Fliegens empfangen und trittst dann auf das Vorfeld. Also das ist natürlich ein ganz außergewöhnliches Gebäude.
Ich fand das auch schick. So, und jetzt wird der geschlossen. Das ist aber doch auch ein Flughafen, der von Privatfliegern genutzt wird.
Na, wie eigentlich jeder Flughafen. Aber was heißt, wird der geschlossen? Jetzt gibt es erst mal am Wochenende diesen Volksentscheid. Dann schauen wir mal.
Der eigentlich keiner ist, weil er nicht bindend ist.
Ja, aber schauen wir erst mal, was der ergibt. Und gehen wir davon aus, dass sich jetzt eine überwiegende Mehrzahl der Stimmenberechtigten für den Erhalt des Flugplatzes Tempelhof ausspricht. Dann ist es natürlich schon die Frage, inwiefern das politisch noch zu rechtfertigen ist, das dann trotzdem gegen diesen erklärten Willen des Volkes durchzuziehen. Also rechtlich ist es korrekt, ist der, finde ich mich nicht irre, der Regierende Bürger nicht dazu gezwungen, dieses Votum auch zu honorieren. Aber politisch ist es natürlich schon eine andere Frage, ob man sich dann weiterhin unbekümmert gegen den Willen des Volkes stellt. Das ist ja politisch schon eine durchaus valide Frage.
Und jetzt sagen ja viele Leute, dass man so den Flughafen A nicht braucht. Und was weiß ich, Stadtflughafen ist natürlich auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Flugzeug kann ja auch auf die Häuser fliegen. Und natürlich wird auch so mit der etwas mangelhaften Wirtschaftlichkeit argumentiert. Was sagst du denn dazu?
Du hast jetzt drei Argumente genannt. Erstens braucht man nicht. Zweitens Sicherheit. Drittens Rentabilität. Die versuche ich jetzt mal strukturiert hintereinander anzugehen. Erstens braucht man nicht. Na ja, da können wir jetzt lange in die Berliner Flughafenplanung einsteigen. Und wie gesagt, das Thema Tempelhof könnte problemlos eine eigene Sendung füllen, die locker zwei Stunden dauern könnte.
Aber jetzt nur mal, um jetzt einige wenige Aspekte zu beleuchten in diesem Zusammenhang.
Und ich muss euch jetzt aus dem Kopf zitieren, insofern möge man mir verzeihen, wenn das nicht auf jede Nachkommastelle stimmt. Aber der BBI, also der neue Flughafen Schönefeld, Berlin Brandenburg International, soll, wenn er dann fertig wird, eine Kapazität von 22 bis 25 Millionen Passagieren haben. Das ist ja schon mal eine ganz beeindruckende Zahl. Und da gibt es ja Aussagen, die sagen, das reicht für Jahrzehnte. Interessanterweise ist es aber so, dass wir heute, also 2007, haben wir, glaube ich, schon 20 Millionen Passagiere. Und jetzt wird ja ständig auch von der Berliner Flughafengesellschaft immer gerne wieder gesagt, wie schnell und wie toll der Verkehr gestiegen ist in den letzten Jahren. Wenn man diese Entwicklung, die jetzt bis jetzt stattgefunden hat in den letzten Jahren, einfach mal weiter extrapoliert bis zur Eröffnung des Flughafens, dann haben wir schon zur Eröffnung von BBI, also wenn dieser neue, tolle, für Jahrzehnte haltene Flughafen fertig ist, sind wir schon an der Kapazitätsgrenze da angelangt. Das heißt, wir können eigentlich direkt wieder weiter ausbauen.
Wobei die allwissende Müllhalde sagt, dass man ihn noch bis 40 Millionen ausbauen könnte.
Ja, da kommen wir jetzt genau in die Details wieder rein. Da gibt es dann wieder diese Geschichten. Wir können ja problemlos Modular weiter ausbauen. Im Prinzip, was die Passagebereiche, also was die Passagierbereiche, also Terminals und so weiter angeht, kann man das in der Tat ganz gut machen. Das Problem ist nur, wir haben ja nur zwei Runways. Erstmal haben wir dann sogar lange Zeit nur eine einzige Start- und Landebahn, weil die nördliche Bahn ja gerade zurzeit abgerissen wird, um die Autobahn da zu bauen. Das heißt, wir haben eine Weile dann nur eine Landebahn. Jetzt stell dir mal vor, auf dieser einen Landebahn passiert was oder du hast, wie du in letzter Zeit jetzt häufig hattest, irgendwie jemand schlittert mal von der Bahn oder so weiter, dann muss die geschlossen werden. Jetzt haben wir nur diesen einen Single Airport, der ist leider ganz Berlin lahmgelegt mal für einen halben Tag oder so. So was dummes aber auch.
Wie lange wird das sein, dass da nur eine Landebahn ist?
Wie lange genau, habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber es ist noch einige Jahre wird es auf jeden Fall so sein. Und jetzt nochmal um die 40 Millionen Passagiere darauf einzugehen, die du eben erwähnt hattest. Genehmigt von den Kapazitäten, also für BBI sind, wenn ich mich nicht irre, ich glaube 360.000 Flugzeugbewegungen. Jetzt kannst du natürlich ausrechnen, 40 Millionen durch 360.000. Das ergibt dann irgendwas mit, ich glaube, ich nehme mal schnell aus, über 140 Millionen durch 360.000. Ich glaube, es ergab 111 Passagiere pro Flug.
Jaja, stimmt, 111.
So, jetzt musst du mal diese 111 Passagiere pro Flug auch tatsächlich erreichen. Jetzt überlegen wir uns mal, was für eine Mischung an Flugzeugen in Berlin hier startet und landet. Wir haben ja hier keine A380, keine 747, also ganz wenige 747, ja, eine schöne Feldmann.
Aber auf dem neuen kann die doch landen, oder nicht?
Jaja, die können da schon landen, aber du musst dir überlegen, wie sieht denn der Verkehr hier aus, die Verkehrszusammensetzung. Fliegen hier alle ständig interkontinental? Nee, die allermeisten hier fliegen innerhalb von Europa oder sogar innerhalb von Deutschland. Der größte Wachstumsträger hier in Berlin sind ja ganz eindeutig die Billifluggesellschaften, also EasyJet, Ryanair und so weiter. Und dann haben wir natürlich echt viel Regionalverkehr. Und jetzt überleg dir mal, wie diese Flugzeuge, was die denn so an Passagierkapazitäten überhaupt haben. Also diese beliebten Turboprops, also Dash 8, Q300, Q400, die haben irgendwo so zwischen 50 und 70 Sitzen. Also je nach Modell. Dann die Canadairjets, die die Lufthansa auch für die regionalen Routen einsetzt. Mal nach Wien oder so. Hast du häufig entweder so ein Flugzeug oder so ein Avro RJ85-Jet. Die haben auch so zwischen 50 und ich glaube, der Avro hat glaube ich 80 ungefähr. So, das sind jetzt also schon mal die Maximalkapazitäten dieser Flugzeuge. Das ist schon mal deutlich unter 111. Und die sind ja nicht immer voll ausgelastet.
Also du meinst, selbst wenn der Flughafen 40 Millionen Fluggäste hinkriegen könnte bei der Zahl der möglichen Flugbewegungen, kommt man einfach auf diese Zahl?
Ich meine selbst eine 737 hat irgendwo so zwischen 100 und 150 Passagieren. Das ist ja wirklich so ein Brot und Butterjet. Und die Frage ist halt, schaffen wir das eigentlich, denn diese 111 Passagiere pro Flug wirklich zu kriegen?
Kurz gesagt, BBI hat nicht genug Kapazität, um wirklich jetzt da zukunftsmäßig, aber dann könnte man ja Tegel noch irgendwie aufhalten.
Könnte man. Nur Tegel, da ist ja auch die, da ist ja eigentlich noch viel zementierter, dass sechs Monate nach Schließ, sechs Monate nach Eröffnung von BBI Tegel zugemacht werden muss. Frag mich jetzt nicht, in welchem Bereich, welchen Abschnitt, welchen Bescheid es jetzt wieder drinsteht, aber das ist sehr klar formuliert. Und das ist ja auch, also wenn man sich jetzt mal von der Logik überlegt, das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Also von wegen, wenn ich jetzt die Argumentation für BBI mit dem Single Airport ist ja, ich habe halt dann Größenvorteile, ich mache das alles über einen Flugplatz. Wenn ich jetzt sozusagen eine Konkurrenz im gleichen Einzugsbereich habe, nämlich den Tegel dann, der ja eigentlich attraktiver ist, weil er ja näher an der Stadt liegt, also für die meisten Reisenden, und ich dann nicht den ganzen Verkehr nach BBI ziehen kann, also den großen Verkehr, wie soll sich das rechnen? Bei Tempelhof ist das weniger das Problem, weil ich da ja schon durch die Begrenzung der Gewichte und der Länge der Bahnen, da kann ich ja schon von vornherein, da kann ich keine 747 landen lassen. Da ist gar kein Platz dafür. Da würde ich eher kleinere Flugzeuge einladen.
Aber Tempelhof ist da nicht viel zu klein, um jetzt in dieser Rechnung mit Millionen und Abertausenden von Fliegereinheiten da noch irgendeinen Ausgleich zu schaffen?
Also sagen wir mal so, es ist halt zu klein, um wirklich eine Bedrohung für BBI darzustellen, also aus meiner Sicht, weil das wird jetzt, selbst wenn da jetzt wieder angenommen, da sind jetzt wieder ein, zwei Millionen Fluglöste im Jahr, oder mehr, das ist ja immer noch vielleicht zur Gesamtsumme nicht relevant, versus Tegel, wo dann im Prinzip noch über 10 Millionen rumlaufen können. Also insofern ist es aus meiner Sicht nicht gefährdend, wirtschaftlich gesehen, für BBI, sondern kann vielmehr eine gute Entlastungssituation übernehmen. Und da kannst du nämlich diese ganzen regionalen Jets problemlos starten und landen lassen. Man darf auch nicht vergessen...
Die sozusagen nur die Slots wegnehmen würden.
Genau, genau. Denn die kritische Ressource beim BBI sind dann ja nicht die Passagierabfertigungskapazitäten, die werden zwar auch mal kritisch sein, aber die kann man relativ einfach ausbauen. Das Problem sind die Start- und Landebahnen. Und wir haben ja zurzeit jetzt in Berlin, wenn ich jetzt nur die Berliner Flugplätze nehme, also die Verkehrsflughäfen, habe ich Tegel zwei Bahnen, habe ich Tempelhof zwei Bahnen und ich habe Schönefeld, hatte ich bis vor kurzem auch zwei Bahnen. So, jetzt gehen wir also von sechs Bahnen, wenn man so will, mit dem BBI auf zwei. Und das ist einfach dann der kritische operationale Engpass.
Das heißt, das Argument für Tempelhof wäre sozusagen, das wäre doch der optimale Flugplatz für kleine Maschinen, um BBI das Geschäft mit den großen Maschinen zu überlassen und da nicht die Slots wegzuklauen.
Exakt.
Und wir sehen, dass die BBI-Betreiber nicht ähnlich?
Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Würden sie das nicht ähnlich sehen?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Es gibt auch, sage ich mal, Fachleute, die hinter vorgehaltener Hand genau das so sagen. Was ja noch ökonomisch dazukommt, ist, dass ja auch die großen Flugzeuge mehr Geld bringen als die kleinen. Also in jeder Hinsicht. Sowohl Landegebühren als auch die Passagiere, mit denen dann Geld verdient und so weiter und so fort. Ja klar. Nur der politische Wille ist halt ein anderer. Und da wurden halt Argumente gebracht, die sich interessanterweise über die Zeit dann immer wieder weiter, ja, verflüchtigt haben, sage ich mal. Du hast zum Beispiel zwei noch angeführt. Du hast noch gesagt Sicherheit. Das war der zweite Punkt. Und der dritte Punkt war die Rentabilität. Jetzt kommen wir mal erst auf das Thema Sicherheit zu sprechen. Seit der Luftbrücke, also seit Ende der Luftbrücke hier, die ja hauptsächlich über Tempelhof abgewickelt wurde, hat es exakt in Berlin einen tödlichen Unfall gegeben. Das war, ich glaube, eine zweimotorige Privatmaschine. Und es gab auch zwei Tote. Die ist im Anflug auf Tempelhof abgestürzt. Also zwei Tote über diesen ganzen langen Zeitraum. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie viele Verkehrstote im Straßenverkehr wir seitdem in Berlin gehabt haben, aber das ist ganz sicher eine sechsstellige Zahl. Jetzt könnte ich argumentieren, also allein auf Basis der Zahlen, wegen Sicherheit, der Luftverkehr scheint ja doch ziemlich sicher zu sein. Da müsste ich nicht lieber mal den Autoverkehr in Berlin verbieten.
Was für Maschinen dürfen denn da landen überhaupt?
In Tempelhof?
Ja, ich meine 747 kommt da nicht runter.
747 kommt da nicht runter. Jetzt frag mich auch nicht, wie genau der Zylostrahmen ist.
Aber alles Props oder auch kleine Jets?
Nö, Jets, gar kein Problem. Bedenke, zu Zeiten, als das noch in der US-Airforce-Basis war, sind die da mit ihren C5A-Galaxies gelandet. Das geht also.
Das ist also alles möglich.
Und die Frage da ist mehr so, wie willst du denn da hinfliegen? Also jetzt angenommen, also maximales Abfluggewicht. Das heißt dann auch maximales Abfluggewicht heißt auch, welche Strecke habe ich denn zur Verfügung, zu gestarten Landung. Wenn ich jetzt Interkontinentalflüge haben will, muss ich ja eine ganze Menge Sprit mitnehmen. Wenn ich da jetzt also ein großes Flugzeug voll beladen mit Sprit und Passagieren werde ich von Tempelhof nicht abfliegen lassen können. Da ist die Bahn zu kurz.
Also es wird sich eigentlich auf so diese, ich weiß nicht, was derzeit fliegen, so 20, 30 Sitze auf Luxair und solche Luxemburg-Verbindungen bin ich selber mal irgendwie in Tempelhof gestartet.
Naja, aber bedenke, bis, ich glaube, bis, was, bis 97 oder 98? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, aber bis, ich glaube, bis zweite Hälfte der 90er Jahre hat die Lufthansa auch ihren ganzen Verkehr, also zum Großteil ihres Verkehrs, über Tempelhof geführt. Es ist also nicht so, dass man jetzt auf das, was jetzt gerade da fliegt, das ist ja mehr oder weniger die Überreste von den Airlines, die nicht alle mehr oder weniger intensiv weggeloggt wurden.
Ich wollte jetzt noch einen Vorstand dafür bekommen, was da noch aufs Zutzen liegt.
Also jetzt mal bei der 737, die ich eben erwähnte zu bleiben, der Brot-und-Butter-Jet, so der Mittelstrecken. Und auch für Kurzstrecken 100 bis 150 Passagiere. Gar keinen Grund, warum die da nicht landen.
Ja, Lärmbelastung ist natürlich dann ein echtes Thema.
Nee, Lärm ist interessanterweise gar kein Thema, selbst wenn du dir die Anwohner mal da in den Statistiken anguckst. Die heutigen Jet-Flugzeuge sind ja nun wirklich leise. Der ist der Straßenverkehr, also wenn da der Diesel-Bromi draußen vorbei, dondert er deutlich lauter. Vor allem Lampeanflug. Ja, das ist mein Ernst. Also Lärm ist natürlich immer eine psychologische Komponente.
Die Frage, was man wahrnimmt als Lärm. Deine Aussage ist sozusagen rein nach Dezibel-A-Gesichtspunkten. Sind die Dinger leiser als der Straßenverkehr?
Ja, es hängt natürlich jetzt davon ab, wo du jetzt wohnst, wenn du jetzt in Friedenau, beispielsweise in einer sehr ruhigen... Ja, im Tempelhof selbst. Was weiß ich, wenn du da direkt am Flugplatz wohnst und vor dir gehen die ganzen Tempelhofer Damm und so. Aber ich kann jetzt auch kein Lambou...
Ich will jetzt auch kein regionalen Podcast machen.
Ich wollte nur mal sagen, wegen der Sicherheit, das erscheint mir eigentlich kein valides Argument.
Okay, dann gibt es noch das Liebe Geld. Ja, das Liebe Geld. Das muss ja auch von irgendwoher kommen.
Genau, und das ist ja das Argument, was am Anfang immer gebracht wurde. Na ja, das rechnet sich ja alles nicht. Es ist viel zu teuer, kann man es gar nicht leisten. Und was jetzt interessanterweise komplett aus der Argumentation verschwunden ist, denn es wurde immer gesagt, der Flughafen Tempelhof erwirtschaftet jedes Jahr so und so viele Millionen Verlust. Ja, das war natürlich Vollkastenrechnung. Das heißt, man hat die ganzen Kosten der Berlin-Brandenburg-Flughafen-Holding, wie sie damals hieß, auch alle auf alle drei Flughäfen verteilt. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen unsinnig, weil die Kosten sind ja dadurch nicht weg, bei dieser Vollkastenrechnung, wenn ich den Flughafen schließe. Man muss eigentlich dann schon gucken, was sind eigentlich die Kosten des Flugbetriebs? Was kosten die denn? Und die sind halt schon wesentlich geringer. Was in Tempelhof wirklich Geld kostet, ist dieses riesige Gebäude.
Aber das muss ja sowieso erhalten bleiben.
Eben, das ist nämlich der Witz. Deswegen ist diese ganze Argumentation so absurd. Und mittlerweile sagt es auch mittlerweile keiner laut. Denn der Flugbetrieb, den aufrecht zu behalten, das ist nicht teuer. Das lässt sich, wage ich zu behaupten...
Ja, was muss man da auch schon machen bei diesen kleinen Maschinen? Da ist auch eigentlich nicht so viel zu leisten.
Eben, die Anlagen sind so alle abgeschrieben. Also, die stehen da schon lang genug da. Was also zu tun ist, ist, die Infrastruktur in Betrieb zu halten. Also Instrumentenlandesystem, Befeuerung, Licht, Tower. Ja, dann hast du Personal natürlich und so weiter und so fort. Das ist das, was für den Betrieb wirklich notwendig ist. Dieses riesige Gebäude da, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Und da kann man sich jetzt nochmal schön fragen, okay, wenn ich jetzt den Flugbetrieb weglasse, wird das Gebäude dann mehr wert oder weniger? Ist dann die Auslastung plötzlich ganz hoch, weil die Leute plötzlich alle da reinströmen? Und es ist nicht eher genau umgekehrt so, dass wenn der Flugplatz wegfällt, natürlich auch die Mieter wegfallen. Wie ja jetzt schon einige schon weggezogen sind, weil sie fürchtet haben, okay, der Flugplatz wird geschlossen. Ich brauche aber weiterhin für meinen Wartungsbetrieb, brauche ich weiterhin einen Hangar, muss ich halt wohl nach Schönefeld umziehen. Also die Argumentation ist, glaube ich, hat sich heute erledigt. Also, dass das nicht profitabel zu betreiben sei.
Interessante Gesichtspunkte. Ich wollte jetzt auch keine Tempelhof-Sendung hier draus machen, aber das fand ich jetzt doch mal ganz interessant, weil es auch topaktuell ist. Dieses Wochenende steht halt diese Abstimmung, welche das politische Gewicht sie dann auch immer entfalten mag, an. Und man denkt nicht so häufig über Flughäfen nach. Ja, jetzt haben wir auch, mal hier ein bisschen auf die Uhr gucken, schon ganz ordentliche Laufzeit. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob es noch irgendwas Wichtiges gibt.
Vielleicht können wir zu dem Thema Flughäfen schon noch ein Wort sagen.
Vielleicht sollten wir es damit auch ausklingen lassen. Was hast du denn noch hinzuzufügen?
Naja, das ist halt Infrastruktur. Und was du auch ganz am Anfang der Sendung sagtest, der Normalbürger nimmt das mit dem Fliegen alles nicht so wahr. Nur als Konsument. Und zwar ganz anders, als wenn du dich in den Bus setzt, da hast du ein intuitives Verständnis, was um dich herum vorgeht. Straßenverkehr, die meisten Leute haben Führerschein, mindestens als Radfahrer sind sie da schon mal unterwegs. Klar, ein Bus ist größer als ein Auto und selbstverständlich gibt es da eine ganz andere Qualifikation, einen Bus zu steuern als ein Auto. Aber das ist alles noch gut nachvollziehbar. Der Luftverkehr hingegen ist wegen seiner Komplexität für die meisten Leute nicht so ohne Weiteres in ihrem Erfahrungsbereich abbildbar. Und dadurch hast du einfach auch ein geringeres Verständnis. Und das sind so komplexe Themen wie jetzt so eine Flughafenschließung oder Bau neuer Flughäfen. Ist deswegen auch nicht ganz so einfach zu vermitteln, wie der Bau einer neuen Autobahn, wo jeder weiß, ja da stehe ich ja immer ständig im Stau, das ist ja blöd. Denn in der Luft merkst du gar nicht, wann immer Stau ist. Höchstens, wenn du dir gesagt hast, wir müssen jetzt wieder im fünften Holding jetzt mal wieder hier.
Noch mal eine Schleife fliegen.
Ja und ich meine, das ist entscheidende Infrastruktur, die also für die Wirtschaftskraft einer Region, jetzt ob das Berlin ist oder ganz woanders, schon von entscheidender Bedeutung ist.
Dann würdest du jetzt auch so einen Flughafen wie Tempelhof dazu zählen. Also er ist auch für die Wirtschaftsleben Berlins wichtig?
Also ich halte es aus den vorgenannten Gründen, was mich angeht. Ich hielt es auf jeden Fall für angezeigt, den offen zu halten, weil er, weil ich denke, dass er als Ergänzungsflughafen zu BBI, nicht als Konkurrenz oder Ersatz, sondern als Ergänzungsflughafen zur BBI eine ganz wichtige Funktion auch in Zukunft. Weil wie gesagt, der Flugverkehr wird ja steigen. Der steigt weltweit, der steigt auch in Berlin.
Aber wie kriege ich halt dieses... Wird er sich denn auch weiter, wie soll ich sagen, ich will jetzt nicht demokratisieren sagen, ich meine vor 100 Jahren, wer hatte da schon ein Auto? Wer hat heute keins? Und mit den Flugzeugen ist es ja auch so, ich weiß nicht, die Erschwinglichkeit ist jetzt noch nicht in den gleichen Bereich gekommen, die Notwendigkeit natürlich auch nicht, aber es fliegen immer mehr Leute, oder?
Aber hallo, aber hallo, guck dir mal an. Als die Planung für BBI begonnen wurde, das war glaube ich 92 oder so, kurz nach der Wende, da gab es noch keine Low-Cost-Carrier. Ich glaube, EasyJet wurde glaube ich 95 oder so erst gegründet überhaupt. Und die sind heute diejenigen, die am stärksten hier in Berlin, die das Ganze extra machen.
Ich meine jetzt gar nicht so sehr die steigenden Passagierzahlen, sondern ich meine die Kosten.
Selber fliegen, selber fliegen.
Also ein Argument hier in dieser Tempelhof-Debatte, hier hängen ja überall Plakate rum, so mit ich zahle doch nicht für einen WIP-Flughafen. Ist denn das nun, also ich meine, wie High Society ist, fliegen?
Naja, also wenn du jetzt mal auf diese schreckliche Plakate, WIP-Flughafen, da möchte ich mir jetzt gar nichts zu äußern, weil es geht ja nicht nur um VIPs, sondern auch um kleine, originale Jets und so weiter, aber das will ich jetzt gar nicht groß beleuchten. Das ist einfach nur sehr populistisch. Aber was die Pilotenpopulation angeht und von wegen elitären, dann geh doch mal auf so einen von den kleinen Brandenburger Flugplätzen raus. Also hier im Umkreis von Berlin gibt es echt genug. Also das kann jetzt Straußberg sein, das kann Samund sein, das kann weiter aus Mienenfarmen, Küritz, Schönhagen, natürlich Fino. Aber hallo, ich meine, da sind wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz normale Leute wie du und ich, viele Segelflieger auch. Also elitär ist das, weiß Gott nicht, wenn du dich da mal umguckst. Also das ist, also, nee, also in Deutschland ganz bestimmt nicht. Also du hast bestimmt Länder, in denen das eine elitäre Geschichte ist, ja. Aber in Deutschland ist es wirklich keine elitäre Geschichte im Sinne von, da steht nur bestimmten Einkommensklassen offen. Überhaupt nicht. Du kannst das im Verein, kannst du auch deinen Flugschein billig machen.
Was muss man so investieren? Billig ist ja relativ.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Also wenn du es jetzt halt an einer Flugschule machen willst, mit allem drum und dran und dann direkt mit Motorflug von vornherein, mit den passenden Berechtigungen und so weiter, kannst du da sicherlich locker 9.000 Euro ausgeben. Aber du kannst auch im Verein das machen. Dann statt, dass du dafür alles in Geld bezahlst, machst du das vielleicht in Leistungen, wo du einfach arbeitest im Verein. Und du kannst dich auch als Segelflieger anfangen und dich dann langsam auch upgraden. Da kannst du eigentlich mit, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, gar keinem Geld, irgendwo, irgendwann musst du dir Sprit bezahlen. Aber da kannst du auch mit sehr viel niedrigeren Kosten das machen.
Also für die Hälfte oder so.
Ja und noch da drunter würde ich sagen. Also klar, speziell wenn du jetzt mit Segelflug oder Motorsegler anfängst, oder UL, das ist noch viel günstiger. Also ultraleicht heißt das.
Und Fliegen selbst, weil wir jetzt eh noch beim Geld angekommen sind. Ich jetzt irgendwie meinen, unseren hypothetischen, ich flieg nach Hamburg von Berlin, Flugmacher mit so einer kleinen Viersitzer-Chessner, die voll besitzt ist. Was muss man dann so ausgeben?
Also Hamburg habe ich jetzt nicht so im Kopf. Hamburg ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerade eine Idealstrecke. Also bei Berlin-Hamburg, da hast du den ICE, der ist eigentlich in 0,0 nix da, direkt in der Stadt. Aber jetzt mal beispielsweise, was ich relativ häufig fliege, ist Berlin-Amsterdam. Wenn du da den Flieger vollpackst, mit vier Leuten zum Beispiel, oder auch nur dreien. Und fliegst du hin und zurück, bist du nicht nur schneller, sondern auch günstiger als mit der Bahn. Also da ist echt nichts dran auszusetzen.
Mit oder ohne Bahncard?
Also mit der Bahncard 100, die ist natürlich nicht zu schlagen. Aber mit Bahncard 50 kannst du es noch hinkriegen. Ja, das kriegst du, glaube ich, noch hin. Da kommst du noch billiger hin und zurück mit dem Flugzeug. Wenn du jetzt alleine fliegst, sieht das natürlich anders aus, wie beim Auto.
Das heißt, auf mittlere Euro-Strecken wird es gerade interessant. So ab 1000 Kilometer oder so.
Ja, das muss jetzt gar nicht. Das hängt doch immer davon ab, wo du jetzt hin willst.
Was hast du denn für eine Reichweite mit so einer 4-sitzigen T-Shaker? Also wie weit kann man denn da so kommen?
Auch das wiederum hängt von den installierten Tanks usw.
ab.
Aber du kannst jetzt von Berlin problemlos nonstop in die Schweiz fliegen oder so was. Ja, das ist ja so kein Thema.
Und ansonsten kannst du auch immer wieder auftanken und weiter fliegen.
Genau, wie in einer Autobahn-Raststätte, da rollst du mal kurz ran und tangst auf. Also kostenmäßig, denke ich, ist das nicht das Problem. Was natürlich ein Thema ist und auch immer bleiben wird, ist es einfach komplexer, stellt höhere Anforderungen als ein Autoführerschein. Du hast halt eine dritte Dimension dazu, die ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit erfordert, die das ganze Verkehrssystem und den dich bewegt etwas anspruchsvoller. Das heißt, fliegen wird, denke ich, auf absehbare Zeit nie ganz so einfach sein wie Autofahren. Du musst halt auch ein bisschen mehr lernen und dich da auch mit entsprechend viel Verantwortungsbewusstsein einbringen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht nur für alle.
Exakt, auf gar keinen Fall. Vielleicht macht ihr halt einfach, du hast es ja selber schon mal mitgemacht, es ist einfach eine Erfahrung, also jedem, der die Möglichkeit hat, mal irgendwo mitzufliegen und es ist wirklich nicht kompliziert, würde ich das echt mal empfehlen, einfach nur mal irgendwo so einen kleinen Flugplatz mal hinzugehen, mal fragen, ob er vielleicht mal mitfliegen darf. Vielleicht auch nur einmal um den Flugplatz rum. Das ist einfach ein Gefühl an eine Unmittelbarheit, Unmittelbarkeit, die man sonst in einem Verkehrsflugzeug, in einem großen Boeing Airbus, was auch immer, nicht erlebt. Und es vermittelt einem, das mag jetzt sehr pathetisch klingen, aber das muss man wirklich mal erlebt haben, um das wirklich beurteilen zu können, es vermittelt einem ein Gefühl von Freiheit und auch Unabhängigkeit und Freude. Das ist unglaublich. Das bietet einem meiner Ansicht nach kein anderes Verkehrsmittel. Und das ist einfach großartig. Und das würde ich also jedem empfehlen, das zumindest mal so auszutesten im Rahmen des Schnupperflugs. Man kann ja einfach mal jemand fragen oder so. Das ist einfach auf jeden Fall wert. Und wenn man dann feststellt, das könnte doch echt was für mich sein. Wie gesagt, so kompliziert ist es nicht. Also man muss da kein Akademiker für sein.
Nur Fliegen ist schöner. Ja, ich denke, schönes Schlusswort. Jetzt haben wir einen großen Bogen gespannt und unsere zwei Stunden auch voll bekommen. Gerade du, der dich immer so über lange Podcasts beklagt. Das hast du jetzt davon. Und den musst du jetzt auch noch mal komplett anhören. Trotzdem vielen Dank für die Einblicke ins Fliegen. Darum ging es mir einfach mal so ein bisschen, auch eine andere Perspektive einzunehmen in so einem Transportsystem, in dem man halt nicht jederzeit Einblicke hat. Die haben wir jetzt bekommen. Und das war es für diese Ausgabe, welche die Nummer trägt, 85, von Chaosradio Express. Und wie immer, wäre ich glücklich über Anregungen und Kritik und Kommentare in unserem Web-Blog unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder wenn ihr Muster habt, könnt ihr uns auch eine Mail schreiben unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Ja, und insofern einfach nur uns bedanken fürs Zuhören. Und ich sage auch danke, Björn, für die Ausführung. Und dann sagen wir schön tschüss von den Hörern. Auf Wiedersehen!